bien je vous propose de démarrer nos
échanges
chers collègues mesdames messieurs
évidemment je vous remercie de votre
présence au Sénat cet après-midi pour
une table ronde qui conclut ne cycle
d'audition que nous menons depuis
février en vue d'actualiser le rapport
que notre délégation aux entreprises du
Sénat a consacré à la RSE les
rapporteurs dont deux sont présents
Martine Berthet et Florence blatrix
compta mais côté en 6 mois le climat
autour de ces sujets a-t-il changé
question
jamais le SG avec les critères
environnementaux sociaux et de
gouvernance a été autant contesté et
jamais autant nécessaire pour les
entreprises
en mai Elon Musk influant patron de
Tesla reprise banni de l'index SCP 500
pour sa gestion sociale Twitter le SG
est une vaste arnaque une escroquerie
cet été dans son numéro du 23 juillet y
économiste considérait que les
investissements agés sont devenus une
mode qui influence de plus en plus sur
les comportements des entreprises
l'État français est en train de revoir
profondément son label ISR
investissement socialement responsable
créé en 2016 un rapport d'inspection
générale des finances ayant établi qu'il
n'était plus crédible ni pertinent et
devait évoluer radicalement sous peine
de cautionner du greenwashing
pourtant les indicateurs
âgés deviennent l'un des principaux
critères d'investissement
l'Union européenne oblige les
entreprises à rehausser le niveau
d'information
extra-financière avec la directive CSRD
en cours de finalisation
une double bataille doit être conduite
celle de l'harmonisation pour faire
converger les référentiels celle de la
simplification pour permettre au PME
souvent embarquée indirectement dans les
chaînes de valeur en effet même si
réglementairement elle pense échapper à
la réglementation VG elles doivent se
mettre à niveau afin de continuer à
accéder à certains marchés et se
financer
parmi les nouvelles obligations qui
pèseront bientôt sur les entreprises et
notamment les PME nous nous intéressons
également à l'affichage social quel est
son coût
sommes aussi étonné de constater que
l'administration continue de demander à
une entreprise qui concourt pour un
marché public de prouver qu'elle est
engagée dans une démarche RSE alors
qu'elle bénéficie de label reconnu par
l'État
nous aimerions avoir votre sentiment à
ce sujet
après un bref exposé luminaire de chacun
d'entre vous nous échangerons de façon
plus interactive particulier avec les
rapporteurs qui complètent leur
information je précise que notre table
ronde sera diffusé en direct et en vidéo
à la demande sur le site internet du
Sénat elle sera également retransmise en
direct sur Twitter et sur linkel je vous
donne maintenant la parole et je vous
propose que nous commencions peut-être
par le MEDEF si vous voulez madame Carla
voilà vous m'entendez oui merci monsieur
le Président merci mesdames les
rapporteurs et merci de pour cette
audition donc je vais je vais introduire
mon cours proposliminaire en deux
parties d'abord des observations
générales de ce pourquoi vous nous avez
auditionné et puis quelques propositions
également quelques observations
générales d'abord
nous constatons tous qui a une véritable
volonté politique en France et en Europe
de construire un modèle économique plus
juste plus durable plus inclusif ça
c'est formellement le politique s'en est
emparé
forte demande de la société civile
également puisque sans cesse la société
civile en appelle à davantage
d'encadrement réglementaire de la
responsabilité des entreprises mais
aussi leur trempe leur transparence sur
des enjeux environnementaux sociaux ou
encore des tiques des affaires
donc les entreprises en définitive sont
soumises de plus en plus à des
obligations de reporting de demandes
d'indicateurs d'engagement actionnarial
de manière directe mais également de
manière indirecte à travers les
obligations du monde de la finance par
exemple
face à cela il y a des enjeux forts pour
les entreprises et pour notre pays de
souveraineté et de compétitivité de nos
entreprises mais finalement de notre
économie également d'une part parce que
pour nos entreprises
toutes ces réglementations et ses
indicateurs et ses reportings implique
une certaine forme d'ingérence dans
l'organisation et l'administration des
entreprises elles-mêmes
mais également cela peut engendrer une
certaine forme de distorsion de
concurrence
vis-à-vis des entreprises de pays tiers
qui n'auraient pas ces mêmes obligations
de reporting
donc la question qui est posée c'est la
définition du modèle européen que nous
souhaitons notamment en matière de
reporting
et
quelle phase de quelle façon ce modèle
européen pourra s'imposer au niveau
international parce qu'il n'y a non
seulement notre compétitivité et notre
souveraineté de nos entreprises de notre
continent mais nous sommes dans un monde
très ouvert encore
pour que les entreprises de notre point
de vue s'empare de ce modèle
nous souhaitons véritablement avoir une
politique globale et systémique pour que
tous les sujets qui paraissent
aujourd'hui pour quelqu'un qui les
découvrirait indépendant et technique
puisse être pris globalement dans leur
considération
par exemple l'absence de considération
d'obligation déjà existante qui ont
précédé les réflexions actuelles la
multiplication
d'initiative avec des calendriers qui
sont parfois non coordonnées voire
contradictoire ton niveau national
européen fait que le cadre législatif et
réglementaire est trop trop instable et
pour une entreprise finalement lui fait
perdre de vue la réalité opérationnelle
qui rendrait applicable ces mesures donc
il y a pas forcément de volonté d'être
contre mais il y a une incapacité à
comprendre la cohérence d'ensemble et la
finalité de l'ensemble
donc il y a véritablement de notre point
de vue un besoin de cohérence et de
stabilité pour pouvoir les mettre en
place ce n'est pas pour les réfutés
c'est pour pouvoir les mettre en place
donner de la visibilité mais surtout ne
pas perdre de vue l'objectif initial du
reporting et de la transparence des
informations qui sont des objectifs de
pilotage de transformation de nos
entreprises et non pas des objectifs de
compliance c'est un objectif stratégique
d'accompagnement de la transformation de
nos entreprises et non pas du contrôle
pour du contrôle
sur le plan j'en ai fini avec la
première partie de mon propos liminaire
sur le plan des
propositions que nous souhaiterions
partager avec vous
nous avons constaté dans nos entreprises
que la RSE est de plus en plus un
facteur véritablement de différenciation
et de compétitivité nous nous sommes
tout à fait pour ces stratégies fondées
sur la Responsabilité Sociétale des
Entreprises
c'est véritablement un changement de
paradigme un changement de pilotage
stratégique dans nos entreprises avec
une vision vraiment intégrée de ce
qu'est la performance d'une entreprise
et pas la fermant la performance
exclusivement financière mais la
performance financière et
extra-financière
mais cette démarche innovante ne doit
jamais perdre de vue l'objectif ultime
d'une entreprise qui est sa pérennité et
sa stratégie de création de valeur de
création de valeur et donc on ne doit
pas l'amputer de facteurs lui permettant
de créer de la valeur
donc le pilier social et sociétal bien
évidemment sont au cœur de notre
actualité dans les entreprises de notre
entreprise si je parle simplement de
sujets comme l'inclusion la diversité et
l'innovation managériale aujourd'hui une
entreprise ne peut plus être performant
soit attractive si elle n'intègre pas ça
dans sa stratégie
donc les propositions qu'on peut mettre
au débat en tout cas à la réflexion sont
les suivantes d'abord travailler à
mettre un cadre lisible et stable sur
les obligations s'appliquant aux
entreprises vraiment lisible stable et
cohérent première proposition
deuxième proposition qui va avec la
première de simplifier ce millefeuille
réglementaire
c'est pas une question de simplification
pour simplification c'est pour
l'applicabilité du réglementaire on veut
bien être aidé à voir comment on dit en
mauvais français des guylines mais il
faut pour cela que ça soit
réappropriable par n'importe quel type
d'entreprise
d'introduire au passage ça a été presque
évoqué dans votre propos introductif
monsieur le Président dans le reste de
la société un même niveau d'exigence
c'est-à-dire que l'entreprise
semble être
dans ce qu'on attend de nous le futur
champion de la vertu
et pourtant on ne travaille pas seul
quand on est dans l'entreprise on est
entouré de parties prenantes et les
nouvelles parties prenantes il y en a
les ONG par exemple et puis bien
évidemment les pouvoirs publics les
institutions publiques les acteurs
publics sont des parties prenantes fort
connus des entreprises nous demandons
simplement le même niveau d'exigence
avec ces différentes parties prenantes
quand nous devons faire ce reporting
extra-financier
quatrième proposition accompagnée et
soutenir les entreprises dans cette
transformation et faire connaître et
reconnaître les bonnes pratiques et les
actions exemplaires des entreprises
alors je vais être un petit peu plus
précise faire connaître et reconnaître
et accompagner les entreprises ça peut
par exemple c'est ce que nous avions
élaboré lors de la campagne des
élections présidentielles en 2022 au
MEDEF
un accompagnement pour être par exemple
la création d'un portail un portail
France transtransition pour faire
connaître déjà tous les dispositifs
existants ce plan environnemental
sociétal et gouvernance mais également
une fois qu'on a une bonne cartographie
des outils existants proposer des outils
pédagogiques des outils opérationnels
pour que les entreprises puissent se
réapproprier derrière cette cartographie
des dispositifs existants ça c'est très
concret c'est un portail comme on l'a
dans France Nîmes par exemple
mieux valoriser également les
engagements volontaires parce que une
entreprise comme je vous l'ai dit
aujourd'hui n'attends pas forcément le
règlement entre guillemets pour bien
faire je mets beaucoup de guillemets à
bien parce qu'il y a on peut qualifier
ça comme on veut mais en tout cas
aujourd'hui au cœur de sa stratégie elle
peut avoir anticipé même certains
règlements et ça ça pourrait être
valorisé valoriser à travers une
reconnaissance par exemple
davantage dans les appels d'offres j'ai
anticipé j'ai une reconnaissance dans
les appels d'offre publique de manière
obligatoire pour l'État et pour les
collectivités
troisième proposition compenser les
contraintes écologiques qui sont
imposées par la loi ou les règlements
par exemple en faisant connaître en même
temps que ces contraintes les
financements dédiés à la transformation
des entreprises sur ces mêmes
contraintes pour se dire finalement je
sais pourquoi je le fais et je vais
t'accompagner et je vais avoir un levier
et je deviens vertueux avec mon
institution
quatrième proposition inciter notamment
les ETI les PME les TPE financièrement à
mesurer leur impact
en quelque sorte si je puis dire qu'il y
a une certaine forme de carotte pour
qu'elles aillent faire ces mesures
d'impact et qu'elle se disent finalement
ce n'est pas un coup ça n'est pas une
corsicion c'est véritablement encore une
fois un levier pour ma performance
d'entreprise
avant dernière proposition
avoir une garantie parfaitement claire
de la réglementation et éviter de
surtreposer au niveau national ce qui
pourrait sortir au niveau européen
dernière
proposition pour être tout à fait
pragmatique et non pas dogmatique de
monter demander une étude d'impact des
nouvelles mesures de reporting
extra-financier applicable
potentiellement applicable aux petites
et moyennes entreprises pour ne pas
perdre de vue l'objectif que je vous
rappelle qui est l'accompagnement à la
transformation des entreprises en vue
d'une meilleure compétitivité d'une
manière attractivité je vous remercie
merci Madame le vice-présidente votre
intervention je vais continuer peut-être
avec le métier madame Grandjean si vous
voulez
bonjour mesdames bonjour Monsieur Merci
Merci de me donner la parole au nom des
entreprises de taille intermédiaire que
je représente ici effectivement en tant
que vice-présidente du métier mais
également en tant que chef d'entreprise
d'une ti familiale qui s'appelle Redex
et qui est implanté dans la région
Centre Val de Loire
en liminaire de cette table ronde nous
voudrions confirmer le métier notre
volonté de poursuivre nos engagements en
termes de RSE et notre intérêt dans le
déploiement de ces normes ou ces affreux
acronymes c'est
rdcsdd alors comme en fait nous les
appelons de nos vœux
nous voudrions tout simplement que ces
textes européens et français soient en
adéquation avec nos moyens avec notre
temporalité dans un contexte économique
actuel qui est très dégradée et que ces
textes se basent sur des critères
pertinents en phase avec nos stratégies
ceci afin effectivement que nos rapports
extra-financiers soient tout aussi
régulier sincère et fidèle que le son
nos rapports financiers
je voudrais rappeler que les ETI
françaises qui ne sont nombreux que de
5400 en France représentent plus du
tiers des emplois industriels un tiers
des exportations françaises et un quart
des investissements aéré D et elles
n'ont pas attendu qu'on leur impose quoi
que ce soit par la loi pour déployer
leurs actions RSE concrètes dans leur
territoire
75% des ETI sont implantés en région
dans les territoires et elles ont une
vision à long terme et ça change tout
lorsque vous regardez à 5 10 ans votre
implantation et la continuation de votre
de votre entreprise donc elles sont
engagées par nature par structure
elle s'engage principalement auprès de
leurs salariés
dans leur territoire auprès des pouvoirs
publics locaux régionaux
et auprès de leur fournisseurs tout ça
pour créer un écosystème
je vais être harmonieux tout simplement
et pérenne
95% des ETI déploie des actions
spécifiques dans leur territoire 60% ont
déjà adopté un label ou une charte pour
mesurer leurs évolutions et la dpef
encore un très joli acronyme est un
outil en fait c'est un outil qui sert
pour les ETI
sous tendre notre politique RSE et un
outil de promotion de nos actions ce
n'est pas un outil de communication
c'est un outil d'action
mais alors maintenant faisons très
attention toutefois à la multiplication
des déclarations obligatoires
les directives qui sont en cours
ne sont pas du tout en phase avec nos
moyens et notre temporalité je vais
prendre un exemple très simple
dans mon entreprise donc 200 salariés en
région Centre-Val de centre Val de Loire
j'ai un tiers temps actuellement qui
s'occupe de répondre aux statistiques
Insee avec ces nouvelles directives je
pense que je vais passer à un pas de 1/3
je vais passer un temps plein
c'est un coup
c'est une opportunité à développer autre
chose et c'est une
un coup qui fera qu'en sorte je ne
pourrais pas agir sur des actions RSE à
la place de simplement déclarer parce
que les textes actuellement s'appliquent
aussi bien pour les grands groupes que
pour les et
la catégorie ETI n'est pas considérée ou
n'est pas regardé dans ces directives
actuellement au niveau européen donc
attention à la multiplication des
déclarations attention également à la
visibilité ça très bien été dit par le
MEDEF nous n'avons aucune visibilité sur
les critères qui sont actuellement
possibles
pour être utilisé alors j'ai apporté la
liste des critères de la plateforme
impacte qui est utilisé à l'heure
actuelle pour la DP voilà
sur cette sur cette quarantaine de
critères moi en tant que chef
d'entreprise de j'utilise déjà une
dizaine de ces critères je ne les
affiche pas je les utilise
c'est principalement des outils
sociétaux et sociaux parce que c'est
pour en tant que chef d'entreprise c'est
vraiment
la part la plus importante c'est quand
même la relation que vous avez avec les
salariés et l'impact que vous avez
localement donc je suis très attachée à
la notion de égalité femme homme heure
de formation par entre parier
travailleur handicapé partage de la
valeur de avec nos salariés mais
également environnementaux c'est-à-dire
que on regarde également la consommation
de nos énergies par unité de production
donc ces critères là il y en a à peu
près une dizaine sur lesquels nous
pourrions moi entreprises rédex répondre
favorablement en suivant cet indicateur
mon voisin sur la zone industrielle a
sans doute d'autres critères qui
l'utilisent ils sont pas mieux les siens
que les miens
par contre il y a certains critères qui
sont totalement insignificatifs pour moi
en tant que di taux de litiges prud'homo
moi je n'ai pas de litige produit
puisque j'ai un climat social très
simple très apaisé et constructif
attention également à ne pas avoir la
double peine c'est-à-dire avoir approuvé
que je n'ai pas de litige prud'hommes
et enfin attention à la complexité du
système c'est à dire que c'est même la
MF qu'il a dit à l'Union européenne ne
faisons pas une nouvelle usine à gaz
c'est mal venu de parler de gaz à
l'heure actuelle mais ne refaisons pas
une usaine à gaz parce que par
constructeur par construction même on
arrivera à l'absurdité du dispositif
et si le dispositif est absurde et bien
il laissera incompréhensible
inutilisable et donc oublier
encore une fois dans un tiroir quelque
part et en fait enfin il faudrait aussi
faire un petit peu attention aux effets
de bord de la statistique quand vous
êtes une ETI vous ne pouvez pas avoir un
nombre conséquent sur lesquels vont
reposer ces indicateurs j'ai pour ma
part dans l'index égalité femme homme il
y a une année où nous avons baissé notre
taux notre parce que en fait cette année
là nous n'avions pas de femme enceinte
c'est tout c'est parce que quand vous
êtes que 200 et que vous n'avez pas 20%
de femmes et 10% de femmes qui sont en
âge de procréer de temps en temps il y a
pas il y a des années où il y a pas de
femmes enceinte pour autant le taux il
était il avait baissé
donc attention aux effets de bord de la
statistique et puis effectivement il va
falloir réfléchir sérieusement une
certaine harmonisation de toutes ces
normes aussi bien en France qu'en Europe
et surtout à l'international les ETI
sont une force pour l'exportation Redex
c'est 85% de notre chiffre à
l'exportation et nous sommes en face de
gens qui ne connaissent absolument pas
ce genre de contrainte ou de normes et
qui en abuse
alors au métier nous voudrions que c'est
voilà c'est 10 mots ce dimensionnement
soit pris en compte et nous prit qu'on
disons que les critères sélectionnés ou
le déploiement de ces critères répondent
à la stratégie actuelle des ETI chacune
la sienne
que ce soit donc adapté à leur
spécificité pour prolonger pour
accompagner toutes nos actions nous
souhaitons mener comme un espèce de
stress test pour connaître quelles sont
les critères qui sont pertinents et puis
effectivement si on pouvait récompenser
un petit peu les bons élèves en fléchant
un petit peu la commande publique pour
ceux qui ont bien travaillé et bien ce
serait bien appréciable donc en
conclusion je voudrais effectivement
dire que le cadre normatif qui va
soutenir cette nouvelle directive c'est
SRD
doit être accompagné adapté à la taille
de l'entreprise que ce soit un grand
groupe une ti une PME et répond de façon
pragmatique
alors volonté continuer à agir en termes
de RSE voilà je me tiens à votre
disposition si vous avez besoin de
d'autres compléments
merci également madame la
vice-présidente on va continuer dans les
PME peut-être
dans l'ordre des voilà des tailles
d'entreprise ça me semble une bonne
logique merci monsieur le Président donc
je me présente je suis Arnaud et Flins
je suis président de la commission des
affaires européennes de la CPME mais pas
seulement je suis aussi chef
d'entreprise et chefs d'entreprise de
PME donc moi je fais des produits pour
l'industrie du luxe dans le
marchandising et le packaging donc des
petits écrins pour les grandes marques
donc j'ai des usines en France mais
aussi à l'étranger et en fait la
problématique que vous nous posez
aujourd'hui est très importante puisque
j'ai l'habitude de dire que nous faisons
de la RSE tous les jours un peu comme
Monsieur Jourdain d'ailleurs
cependant
il faut que ça reste un acte volontaire
et c'est ce que nous souhaitons à la
CPME je l'ai entendu au métier au MEDEF
le caractère volontaire est extrêmement
important pourquoi encore tirer en
augmenter le fardeau qui est présent
déjà sur nos PME par des choses que nous
faisons déjà c'est intrinsèquement lié à
ce que nous sommes nous sommes des chefs
d'entreprise engagés sur le terrain au
plus proche de nos salariés
ces questions sont prises en compte moi
dans mon entreprise je réponds à
d'énormes tous les jours je suis dans le
dans le secteur du cuir aussi nous
respectons des normes
européennes riches nous sommes
adhérents à ecoVadis nous avons d'autres
points comme des normes comme SA 8000
qui sont des normes sociétales et
environnementales donc c'est des choses
que nous faisons au quotidien
deuxième point important dans mon propos
liminaire c'est
l'importance je l'ai déjà entendu aussi
au métier au MEDEF d'éviter le
chevauchement de toutes ces nouvelles
directives c'est impressionnant ça tombe
de partout on va parler de ruissellement
tout à l'heure mais c'est c'est ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui donc il faut
évidemment pouvoir avoir une
structuration pour éviter ce
mille-feuille qui va tomber sur nos PM
et ça c'est très important donc je vous
parlerai des impacts directs indirects
très importants sur les PME on en a
parlé de manière globale moi ce que je
veux c'est rentrer dans les détails
aujourd'hui sur la directive de devoir
de vigilance ou sur la directive CSRD on
nous parle d'un critère de PME qui est
totalement et pas du tout ce qu'on a vu
auparavant c'est-à-dire le critère PME
était défini en 2003
sur une base de 50 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires et 500 salariés
pourquoi c'est de direct pardon
250 oui maintenant mais on avait une
base de 50 millions en 2003
donc c'est de directives redéfinissent
c'est
ces critères en passant à 40 millions de
chiffre d'affaires je serai directement
concerné madame a un tiers de personnes
dédiées à répondre aux différentes
enquêtes de l'Insee moi j'ai déjà un
salarié pour répondre à tout ce dont je
vous ai parlé plus accroître ce genre de
réponse ça va être extrêmement compliqué
en plus dans la mise en place je vais
dans un site européen pour remplir
les différentes questions auxquelles je
suis assujetti c'est un problème parce
que moi je me suis encore une PME d'une
taille plus importante que les autres
mais parler à un chef d'entreprise de
TPE j'ai quelques salariés qui se tapent
le boulot
c'est le chef d'entreprise c'est lui qui
va faire ça lui-même donc ça veut dire
tout le temps qu'il va passer à faire sa
déclaration il va pas le passer à autre
chose à ces commandes à son client et
surtout aussi à ses salariés
au bien-être de ses salariés
donc
nous ce que nous souhaitons c'est
revenir à la définition de la PME de
2003 et ça c'est très important alors on
parle des sociétés à forte impact alors
on définit les fortes impacts on met un
panier d'oser on ne sait pas comment moi
je suis une PME dans le cuir je vois pas
pourquoi le cuir est là dedans puisque
on est une des matières recyclée par
excellence depuis plus de 2000 ans bon
ça passons donc nous souhaitons revenir
évidemment que ce soit des PME à forte
impact ou des PME tout court à un seuil
de 500 salariés et 50 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires et puis alors là
l'effet ruissellement actuellement de
ces nouvelles directives c'est qu'une
PME inclut dans une chaîne
d'approvisionnement ou d'une chaîne de
distribution va être responsable
et ça a des conséquences financières
puisqu'elle peut perdre toute aide
publique
elle sera responsable et elle aura
à contrôler sa chaîne de distribution et
sa chaîne d'approvisionnement à une plus
un n+2n - 2 N -3 on ne sait pas où ça
s'arrête ça s'arrête aux consommateurs
et ça s'arrête quoi aux matières
premières extrêmement compliqué pour un
chef d'entreprise de PME de contrôler sa
chaîne d'approvisionnement et sa chaîne
de distribution
alors on nous parle aussi de caractères
bien établi dans les relations
commerciales je suis désolé de rentrer
un peu plus vraiment dans le cœur du
sujet mais c'est le diable se cache dans
les détails là-dedans pour nous chefs
d'entreprise
le caractère bien établi la relation
commerciale qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
je sais pas
j'aimerais bien que ça soit défini
on parlait de test ça c'est très
important les études d'impact ont été
fait sommairement aujourd'hui ces deux
directives doivent passer par un test de
TI un test de grand de grands groupes un
test de PME et un test pour pour les
artisans pourquoi ne pas mettre ça avant
de l'implémenter à devant le
devant des tests sur des entreprises
alors je vous parlerai aussi évidemment
des garanties contractuelles on adaptées
et des mesures d'accompagnement
insuffisantes on a bien noté dans ces
deux directives que les PME seraient
évidemment enfin aider alors très très
bien on est très content d'être aidé
mais encore une fois le diable se cache
dans les détails comment être aidé ça
veut dire on peut avoir un effet aussi
pervers qui est de dire les grands
groupes vont dire bah oui mais non les
PME
on va peut-être travailler avec des
groupes intermédiaires ça sera plus
simple pour nous parce que sinon il va
falloir aider qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
aider donc bien définir les aides au
départ
comment va se caractériser l'aide que ça
soit bien clair pour le grand groupe que
ça soit bien clair pour la PME et que
tout le monde soit d'accord sur les
enjeux car ça peut créer cet effet
pervers
je vous parlerai aussi de la différence
madame lavé ok entre l'APM ou
l'entreprise hors Union Européenne et
l'entreprise
inclut dans le marché européen on doit
dans un dans le premier cas à définir un
chiffre d'affaires européen et dans
l'autre un chiffre d'affaires mondial
alors je comprends pourquoi ça a été
fait ainsi ceci dit ça crée une
distorsion de concurrence à l'intérieur
de l'Union pourquoi des avantages il est
PME de l'Union par rapport à celle qui
sont extérieures à l'Union
une question à laquelle je n'ai pas de
réponse
quoi d'autre encore et j'en ai fini je
passerai la parole à Monsieur Burban
et bien
les sanctions
alors là c'est absolument terrible pour
une PME
plus d'aide 0 rien on est pris dans le
dans la chaîne de valeur de production
plus aucune aide publique
terrible pour un pour une pour une pour
une PME en plus on peut mettre la
responsabilité de nos administrateurs de
PME en quoi on peut être responsable de
ce genre de choses encore une fois
on le fait au quotidien notre boulot
dans nos entreprises la RSA est au cœur
de nos entreprises moi j'ai fait un bien
un bilan carbone le scope un SCOP 2
scope 3 pour analyser tous ces facteurs
je le sais de manière non contrainte de
manière volontaire et c'est ce que nous
souhaitons et c'est un petit peu la
conclusion que je dirais par rapport à
cette audition il faut garder ce
caractère volontaire les chefs
d'entreprise font leur boulot au
quotidien et le fond avec leur salarié
avec leur terroir pour pouvoir avancer
et voilà merci beaucoup de nous écouter
ça nous donne la possibilité de vous
exprimer nos frustrations et aussi de
rentrer dans les détails
et donc je pourrais dire oh bah super on
est absolument pas concerné puisque bon
sauf que manque de peau on a
malheureusement beaucoup de
sous-traitants
vous savez sans doute tous d'ailleurs
que l'avion du futur
un certain nombre de pièces sont
préparées par des artisans qui ont 7 5
salariés notamment dans les Pays de la
Loire
et bien ils sont concernés parce que
Airbus sous-traitent très bien mais donc
mon pauvre artisan et que c'est cette
salariés ben il est concerné par ces
dispositions voilà bon alors je vais pas
redire ce que tout le monde a dit et en
particulier la CPME tout à l'heure c'est
des en fait toute la RSE a été pensé
alors que ça part de comment dire d'un
bel objectif et objectif que nous
partageons tous moi j'ai un président
qui dit toujours on respire tous le même
air donc on a tout intérêt à polluer
moins avoir des comportements vertueux
c'est une évidence simplement ensuite
c'est les moyens pour parvenir à cet
objectif et alors ce qui est terrible
parce que ça c'est un syndrome très
États-Unis
d'ailleurs il y a cette cabinet parisien
d'avocats qui semblent aujourd'hui qui
ont été mis dans des réseaux des
États-Unis qui d'ailleurs qui qui
récupère la marge et alors tous les
soirs ils sont là à faire du reporting
voilà ils expliquent à New York que ce
qu'ils font à Paris
et là c'est pareil donc on est rentré
dans une mécanique mais on marche sur la
tête je pense qu'on marche sur la tête
et qui plus est alors parce que tout ce
qui relève de la RSE tout ce qui est de
la normalisation tout ce qui est du
comportement en fait ça relève depuis
toujours d'ailleurs c'est le fondement
de même de la Communauté européenne
puisque par définition la Communauté
européenne c'était une communauté
d'entreprise et c'est très bien je
loin de moi l'idée de contester l'Union
européenne simplement du coup il a fallu
établir des règles pour assurer une
concurrence saine et loyale mais est-ce
qu'on a pris les bons outils pour
assurer cette concurrence saine et
loyale moi je crains que non
et là je pense au plus petit parce
qu'effectivement et ça a été dit par
tout le monde alors déjà que pour une
entreprise donne une certaine taille
parce que du coup il faut des
collaborateurs alors c'est très bien
vous allez me dire c'est bien finalement
ça crée des emplois ils sont là à
rédiger leur rapport machin très bien
bon sauf que c'est pas la vocation d'une
entreprise
sa vocation c'est de produire en
desservices et c'est pas faire du
rapport pour le rapport or on tombe dans
cette espèce de de syndrome et qui est
dramatique pour les plus petites
entreprises alors je vais vous donner un
exemple qui est assez ancien donc il y a
prescription est-ce que je vais dire ne
concerne pas nos organisations mais je
parlais de la fabrication de glace
alimentaire
dans les années 80
dans le cadre de l'Union européenne
puisque c'est déjà
l'Union qui établissait des normes et
très bien et donc pour que les règles de
concurrence soient identiques pour tout
le monde on a établi des règles des
normes pour fabriquer la glace
alimentaire et je dis bravo puisque
effectivement manger une glace ça peut
tuer
voilà parce que un produit alimentaire
si les mal préparés s'il est préparé
dans de mauvaises conditions
effectivement ça peut développer de la
légionellose etc enfin bref quelque
chose qui est dangereux sauf que
qu'est-ce que ça eut pour conséquence
cette superbe note des années 80 et ben
c'est que ça empêché tous les artisans
pâtissiers qui faisaient des glaces et
ben ça a été terminé puisqu'en fait il
fallait acheter des équipements qui
étaient très coûteux et qui ne
permettait pas il a fallu ramer ensuite
des années et des années pour faire en
sorte que la norme je dis ça parce que
derrière il y avait quand même des
grands groupes industriels pas
nécessairement français d'ailleurs mais
qui avait intérêt à parce que il faut
être clair le monde économique c'est pas
un monde de bisounours le monde
économique c'est d'ailleurs c'est
dommage parce que je le disais avant la
crise en Ukraine mais le monde
économique c'est le monde où il y a
encore des batailles où il y a des
conquêtes de marché et c'est normal
enfin je veux dire c'est ça la limite
c'est la concurrence voilà sauf que si
cette concurrence elle est faussée parce
qu'on vous a établi des règles qui font
que vous excluez un certain nombre
d'entreprises et notamment à cause de
leur taille donc je parle avec un peu de
véhément mais pourquoi parce que c'est
la vie d'un grand nombre d'entreprises
françaises il faut jamais perdre de vue
que on a des bouts de très beaux
fleurons dans l'économie française on a
des très belles PME mais 98% des
entreprises françaises ont moins de 50
salariés
98 et si je parle rien des moins de 20
on est à 95% et que ces 98% de moins de
50 c'est pas négligeable en termes
d'emploi puisque c'est plus de 50% de
l'emploi salarié donc faisons attention
à ne pas aller prendre de mesure qui
finalement aurait des conséquences
catastrophiques pour l'existence même du
tissu économique et ce que je dis ça
vaut pour la France mais parfois on dit
à une grande différence en Allemagne en
Allemagne aussi certes il y a pas 98% de
l'entreprise de moins de 50 il y en a
que 97% bon ça c'est vrai bon mais et
c'est vrai que le 1% n'est pas
négligeable bon mais ce qui montre qu'on
n'est pas si différent donc c'est un
problème global je terminerai donc vous
aurez compris que nous on est quand même
très inquiet ce d'autant que dans les
discussions qu'on peut avoir à Bruxelles
avec les autorités compétences il ne
nous rassure pas du tout puisque l'idée
c'est qu'au contraire
pour rendre tout ça plus vertueux
il faudrait aller plus loin possible
voir baisser les seuils voilà donc c'est
pas rassurant du tout et après je
terminerai par ce qu'elle dit
Arnaud afflelin
mais ça a été dit aussi par Dominique
carlac et Sylvie Grandjean c'est la
démarche volontaire je pense qu'on a des
entreprises quel que soit leur taille
qui sont prêtes à rentrer dans les
mécaniques voilà parce que comme je le
disais tout à l'heure c'est un intérêt
collectif voilà
que ce soit au plan environnemental
comme ce soit au plan social ou sociétal
une entreprise qui fonctionne bien c'est
une entreprise vous les salariés sont
heureux et où les et du coup ils sont
plus productifs excusez-moi de le dire
de manière aussi triviale donc c'est
notre intérêt collectif
et de plus et là je pense surtout au TPE
mais ça peut aussi concerner les PME il
faut
prôner et soutenir les actions
collectives en clair c'est pas
entreprise par entreprise enfin je pense
à moi avec mes entreprises quand en
moyenne trois quatre salariés c'est pas
individuellement donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut accompagner aussi ce que font les
organisations professionnelles en action
collective et je vais m'arrêter là parce
que je serais beaucoup trop long mais je
n'ai aucune des 120 fédérations
adhérentes à l'u2p qui n'a pas mené des
actions collectives que ça soit les
coiffeurs les esthéticiennes les
boulangers les bouchers ils ont tous des
actions collectives en matière de RSE y
compris dans le champ des professions
libérales voilà et donc c'est vers ça
qui va aller qu'il faut aller se dotant
que en allant vers des actions
volontaires et des incitations à mon
avis on courage à plus et on créera
moins parce que je pense parfois
excusez-moi de le rappeler qu'il y a eu
les gilets jaunes et que dans les gilets
jaunes mal malheureusement on avait
aussi je pense à un certain nombre
d'artisans mais même des professionnels
libéraux et donc il faut arrêter de
penser qu'il faut encore accroître la
charge parce qu'il y a la charge des
prélèvements obligatoires mais la charge
administrative parce qu'on parle depuis
40 ans de simplification et là on est
dans un bel exemple si on continue vers
une complexification totale
alors merci collectivement mesdames
messieurs pour votre engagement
sur ces sujets là donc je pense que les
rapporteurs ont fait leur miel de ses
propos moi j'aurais peut-être un appel à
vous faire parce que ça a été évoqué
alors sur la simplification je j'y
mettrai même pas le bout du pied parce
que il y a des rapports très volumineux
là-dessus et on sait pas trop où ils
atterrissent mais
on pourrait reprendre au moins les
derniers et les pousser un petit peu par
le réseau européen donc ce qui
m'intéresserait parce que vous l'avez
évoqué à plusieurs reprises c'est
l'iniquité de traitement entre
la réglementation qui s'applique aux
entreprises européennes et à celles hors
Europe
ce Président vous l'avez cité donc si
vous avez dans vos dans vos services
centraux
syndicaux patronaux
la possibilité de faire une liste
éventuelle des différentes inéquités
relevées
pour qu'on
engagement à ce moment-là d'en faire la
synthèse et puis on vous tiendra au
courant mais d'agir je pense que vous le
faites avec vos organisations
directement à Bruxelles mais c'est
toujours vu comme une intervention de
lobby etc bon on peut le faire sur le
plan politique aussi je veux dire on a
des réseaux politiques
parlementaires et on peut je vous
propose ça de faire remonter par ce
canal pour que des élus s'emparent
plutôt que les fonctionnaires du sujet
alors est-ce que ça ira plus vite plus
loin plus fort j'en sais rien mais au
moins on aura tenté quelque chose sur un
sujet qui est crispant parce que qui est
des normes vous l'avez tous dit c'est
sans doute nécessaire parce que tout le
monde n'est pas forcément bien
intentionné dans dans tout ça même s'il
y a une bonne volonté générale mais qui
est une inéquité de traitement en
défaveur des entreprises européennes
alors je parle même pas des entreprises
françaises parce qu'on sur rajoute
évidemment nous à notre niveau tout ce
qu'on peut pour handicaper nos acteurs
économiques bref apprenons déjà le sujet
tel qu'il a été exprimé si vous avez
quelques éléments à nous fournir
madame Boutry en fera la synthèse et on
vous tiendra au courant du voilà du
cheminement qu'on pourrait faire
apporter à cela première proposition de
ma part alors maintenant c'est plus
c'est pas tellement mon rôle
d'intervenir dans le débat
effectivement regarder précisément le
degré d'iniquité par rapport au cadre
des différents pays mais malheureusement
assez rapidement dans la réflexion ça
devient binaire
il y a ce
qui veulent se doter d'un cadre
pour leurs entreprises et se faisant se
draper de la poche de la vertu politique
et puis il y a ceux qui pour qui ce
n'est pas indispensable c'est binaire
donc nous on est dans la surenchère
de cette poche de la vertu et puis des
pays en profitent donc c'est pour ça que
je réinsis sur des propositions que nous
avons fait les uns et les autres
qui sont la valorisation des démarches
volontaires la reconnaissance
c'est-à-dire si on veut prendre le
leadership on viendra pas en arrière
heureusement malheureusement j'ai pas à
qualifier la chose nous le faisons tous
comme nous l'avons rappelé comme des
Monsieur Jourdain si véritablement on
veut prendre le leadership de la
performance économique extra-financière
il faut pour cela et pour le doper que
les entreprises est intérêt à
l'accélérer je dis pas intérêt à le
faire parce qu'elles le font déjà
intérêt à l'accélérer et on a émis les
uns et les autres des propositions pour
qu'il y ait une reconnaissance sur leurs
compétitivité déjà vis-à-vis
des institutions qui imposent ou
réfléchissent ce genre de cadre
merci de votre marque en effet
évidemment il s'agit de couvrir le mieux
disons en étant même encore mieux du
coup ceux qui font rien
un boulevard alors monsieur le président
je vais laisser parler Sandrine après
mais simplement un point de comparaison
le devoir de vigilance français en 2017
c'est 5000 salariés aujourd'hui c'est
moins de 500
il est vrai qu'on vit avec ces deux
textes
bruxellois une petite révolution en
matière de RSE là où la RSE et c'est ce
que nous prenons tous sont vraiment des
actions l'engagement d'un chef
d'entreprise l'engagement de des
salariés qui sont qui sont là dans
l'accompagnement de ces mesures c'est le
les discussions avec les parties
prenantes là où c'est vraiment ce sont
des actions vertueuses alors qu'on
pousse de manière volontaire mais on l'a
dit sur tous ces bancs les entreprises
vraiment sont très engagées une vraie
conviction et il y a des retours
j'allais dire quand elles sont vraiment
engagées elles comprennent qu'elles vont
pas revenir en arrière c'est à dire que
c'est un vrai mouvement de fond
aujourd'hui effectivement on vit une
petite révolution avec ces textes
puisque cette RSE vertueuse exemplaires
se transforme en data en RSE data
c'est-à-dire que là là où vous étiez
engagé dans des démarches vertueuses et
probantes certes là vous allez en fait
ce qui va se passer c'est que vous allez
déléguer à votre expert-comptable à un
auditeur en tout cas un prestataire
extérieur ce fameux reporting
extra-financier qui devient une vous
avez dit une usine à gaz non seulement
une contrainte mais une difficulté sans
nom aujourd'hui
on a travaillé puisque on les a eu sur
les projets de standard donc ces fameux
outils de reporting pour les pour les
grands groupes
c'est
très standard 130 indicateurs d'une
complexité rare ce sont des projets
aujourd'hui pour les entreprises les
plus grandes entreprises donc je
laisserai éventuellement le Medef le
dire mais c'est déjà très très compliqué
avec une déjà il faut les comprendre
c'est c'est il faut pouvoir collecter
les informations il faut pouvoir
renseigner ces standards vous avez
souvent une granularité dans
l'information qui est demandé qui est
extrêmement difficile à obtenir voilà
donc nous ce qu'on dit pour les petites
entreprises sur ces sujets là
bruxellois de directives on est
effectivement vous l'avez dit totalement
favorable à l'objectif qui est
transparence de de dire ce que l'on fait
avec des données fiables comparables etc
ça c'est normal mais la complexité de la
mise en oeuvre va être telle que les
entreprises les nôtres les petites
entreprises qui aujourd'hui sont pas
dans le dans le périmètre mais vous
l'avez bien compris il y a une une
inclusion automatique des PME par la
chaîne de valeur donc à mon et aval
maintenant avec la directive de devoir
de gilance donc là ça devient vraiment
très compliqué
donc une telle complexité qu'est-ce qui
va se passer c'est que nous ce qu'on
pense c'est que les entreprises vont se
retrouver évincées du marché évincé de
certains investissements parce qu'elles
ne pourront pas répondre à ces standards
alors aujourd'hui les standards qui
devront être appliqués par les les
petits enfin les PME côté qui sont
assujettis ou les PME qui souhaiteraient
volontairement y aller pour nous ça doit
pas du tout être la déclinaison de ces
grands standards soit vraiment des
standards spécifiques pour les PME avec
peu d'indicateurs vous l'avez dit des
indicateurs qui parlent au métier de la
PME qui parle à son secteur sinon
vraiment là on va perdre beaucoup
beaucoup de monde en route et c'est une
vraie inquiétude de notre part
et pour terminer pour pas être trop
longue ça fait 10 ans 15 ans que la CPME
aussi
soutient vous le savez le développement
de ces référentiels sectoriels RSE qui
parle aux métiers de l'entreprise la RSE
c'est un tronc commun d'indicateurs mais
c'est aussi et surtout les enjeux
sectoriels de l'entreprise il faut que
ça parle à l'entreprise notamment plus
petite d'entre elles et nous demandons
avec tout le monde la valorisation de
ces référentiels qui sont nombreux on
l'a dit la majorité des secteurs
professionnels ont un référentiel RSE
dans l'imprimerie vous avez des
référentiels dans l'automobile vous avez
des référentiels les ingences de
communication etc les coiffeurs ont des
il y a des actions collectives
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas reconnu dans la
commande publique ou même par les grands
donneurs d'ordre privé aussi par la
commande privée donc là il y a un vrai
travail et on essaie vraiment avec les
pouvoirs publics de faire en sorte et
vous l'avez vu que le mieux 10 ans soit
reconnu par rapport au moins 10 ans
aujourd'hui dans les faits c'est pas le
cas et c'est vraiment encore un combat
qu'il faut qu'on mène pour voilà arriver
à
valoriser ses efforts qui sont des
efforts parce que pour l'entreprise
c'est effectivement des compétences un
investissement à long terme nous à la
CPME on a travaillé sur éventuellement
c'est des avantages qui pourraient être
associés à ces à ces référentiels à ces
démarches pour que évidemment il y ait
un avantage un intérêt à agir pour les
entreprises voilà merci
merci alors je me tourne vers les
rapporteurs questions peut-être l'une ou
l'autre Martine alors bonjour à toutes
et tous Merci beaucoup pour
pour les éléments que vous nous avez
apportés qui sont tous très intéressants
et effectivement on comprend bien que
en plus avec les difficultés qui
s'annoncent pour vos entreprises
notamment par rapport au coût de
l'énergie l'augmentation les
revalorisations salariales etc
c'est vrai que là on vous en rajoute une
couche au niveau des coûts pour vos
entreprises qui paraît avec ce que vous
ne savez exposé tout de même assez
importante alors justement est-ce que
vous avez pu faire des chiffrages de ces
coups peut-être par tranche en fonction
de la taille des entreprises ce serait
intéressant d'avoir quelque chose de
plus palpable plus concret au niveau des
coûts que cette mise en place de la
nouvelle directive européenne vous
entraîne
peut-être aussi un j'avais plusieurs
questions mais vous avez finalement
répondu à pas mal de choses
d'ores et déjà sur le verdissement de la
commande publique vous venez madame
Bourgogne de nous donner quelques
éléments mais est-ce que vous en avez
peut-être un peu plus c'est ce que vous
sentez quand même à frémissement au fur
et à mesure que vous avancez dans la
mise en place de la RSE
c'est vrai que
cette RSE était intéressante je repense
au début des certifications des
entreprises voilà l'entreprise qui
voulait enfin avait tout intérêt pour
gagner des parts de marché être plus
justement vertueuse aller dans les
certifications tout au début est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que de mettre ce
enfin ces nouvelles obligations
obligatoires pour toutes les entreprises
finalement ça vous coupe un peu l'herbe
sous les pieds dans le domaine de la
concurrence et dans le domaine de
d'aller plus loin vis-à-vis de salariés
pour les fidéliser etc ce que ça vous le
ressentez vraiment comme pénalisant de
ce point de vue là
j'avais une dernière question que je ne
retrouve pas oui par rapport à l'Union
européenne
donc vous avez parlé monsieur Burban
tout à l'heure de l'Allemagne
globalement au niveau de l'Union
européenne quelle grosse différence
sentez-vous et quel pays ont mis
en application
les nouvelles mesures de façon plus
intéressante que ce que nous pouvons
avoir en France qu'est-ce qui vous
paraît intéressant d'aller chercher dans
d'autres pays européens sur la mise en
application de la directive
voilà merci
Florence
donc qui qui veut
intervenir pour répondre à Martine
Berthet madame Jean
oui je voulais simplement donner le
chiffre qui est publié par la Commission
européenne sur le coup vous avez
mentionné alors je suis moi-même et par
le coup qu'ils annoncent 100.000 euros
pour la première année
100000 euros je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte mais pour une PME c'est
peut-être son résultat d'exploitation
pour une ETI c'est une grosse partie
c'est peut-être ce qui est donné en
participation pour un grand groupe c'est
peut-être pas grand chose mais enfin ça
fait tout de suite 100000 euros donc
c'est la Commission européenne qui qui
donne cette cette donnée puis je voulais
également parler de la dichotomie entre
ce qui est dit à Bruxelles c'est-à-dire
que on va simplifier on va simplifier et
puis la réalité le verdissement de la
commande publique objectivement on n'en
voit pas du tout les résultats par
contre on voit bien la complexité qui
s'amoncelle ça effectivement et peu
importe après tout si cette complexité
elle est pour chacun pour tous du même
niveau nous sommes chefs d'entreprise
nous chercherons de marcher nous aurons
un nouvel oncle d'attaque nous une
nouvelle façon d'aborder le marché tant
que chacun de nos concurrents aura la
même les mêmes contraintes ou les mêmes
envies d'avoir des normes mais quand
nous donne internationaux
pour ma part un grand groupe prêtre très
très grand groupe de la sidérurgie
métallurgie
Englos indien pour ne pas le nommer fais
un appel d'offre sur une installation
qui va doit être faite en Inde mes
concurrents ils sont italiens allemands
coréen japonais et chinois
pensez-vous que les Coréens les Japonais
et les Chinois ont les mêmes contraintes
que nous absolument pas et que
pensez-vous que le grand donneur d'ordre
qui doit séparer de grandes vertus
également comment est-ce qu'il va
sélectionner cette installation en Inde
ça va être le prix et seulement le prix
donc on va sortir de ces marchés là
et c'est déjà un peu le cas donc on se
positionne sur des marchés de niche on
attaque différemment voilà
j'ai pas de meilleur chiffre que le
métier sur les 100000 euros pour pour y
passer entre guillemets ma
collaboratrice complétera le cas échéant
sur le vernissement de la commande
publique si on zoome un peu sur le cas
de la France nous on a regardé un petit
peu les chiffres en tout cas ce qui
existait donc en effet on constate qu'il
y a vraiment une attention croissante
des acheteurs publics sur les engins
environnementaux donc je dirais la
politique est bien suivie d'une
politique d'achat qui versdirait
l'économie donc quand on a recensé les
marchés publics à plus de 90 000 euros
sur l'observatoire économique de la
commande publique de Bercy on voit
effectivement que en gros les contrats
qui intégreraient des clauses
environnementales on est autour de 18
19% contre 11 à 13 % en 2017 donc on a
pris 5 points de d'exigence sur les
contrats avec les clauses
environnementales les collectivités
c'est un petit peu pareil puisque il y a
le ma promotion des achats publics
socialement écologiquement responsable
qui est mis en place donc jusqu'ici je
dirais que l'acheteur public tient bien
compte de cette volonté politique le
problème c'est ce qui vient de te dire
sur le plan international et c'est là où
c'est gravissime c'est que si une
entreprise si dureurgique
indienne voilà
consulte des compétiteurs de Madame sur
toute la planète quand vous êtes sur un
marché à 90 000 euros en France avec
votre acheteur public français et que
vous êtes une PME française et qu'on
vous dit voilà il y a des clauses
environnementales mais qu'à la fin
c'est un compétiteur international qui
gagne le marché au prix vous dites mais
on est devenu fou on se met une balle
dans le pied
je connais bien le secteur il y a pas
que des grandes entreprises du CAC 40 au
MEDEF moi j'ai une entreprise de 64
personnes
il y a des marchés sur lesquels on ira
plus
qui sont des marchés publics français en
revanche mes compétiteurs internationaux
pourront continuer à y aller
on embauche les mêmes jeunes qui
viennent des mêmes écoles
je peux ajouter pardon quelques éléments
sur la question du coût pour les
entreprises de la mise en place de ces
nouvelles de ces nouvelles mesures
alors on n'a pas de chiffrage exact mais
quand on a travaillé justement sur la
réponse à les frag sur sur ces
indicateurs qui évoquaient Sandrine
Bourgogne précédemment ce qu'on a
constaté donc déjà juste pour revenir
sur les 130 points d'indicateur quand on
parle par exemple de la taxonomie verte
européenne qui avait commencé à être
mise en place cette année ça compte pour
un point d'indicateur des 130 évoqués
par Sandrine donc chaque point
d'indicateur peut être en fait
conséquent dans les informations qui
sont qui sont demandées
on a fait une quinzaine de réunions avec
près de 150 membres qui étaient présents
donc qui représentait des tailles
d'entreprises assez variées mais
notamment des grands groupes qui
mettaient en place déjà la dpef au
niveau français
et ce qui était intéressant de constater
c'est que au-delà du nombre de
d'indicateurs qui est conséquent
ça change aussi en fait la manière de
penser dans les entreprises c'est à dire
que ça rapproche des fonctions
financières et extra-financières qui ne
se parlaient pas forcément de cette
manière là jusqu'à présent donc ça
nécessite aussi de repenser des process
humain enfin en termes de métier mais
aussi informatique en termes de
remontées des données donc d'avoir des
transformations en termes de système
d'information qui qui sont importantes
et qui vont aussi représenter un coût et
un grand groupe qui avait déjà mis en
place donc la dpef nous disait que rien
que sur la taxonomie son équipe passait
à priori de une personne à 4-5 personnes
pour le reporting taxonomie donc ça
reste voilà conséquent
merci de ces précisions peut-être passer
la parole à Madame blatrix compta
bonjour à toutes et à tous et merci de
ces propos très francs sur vos
difficultés
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
sur la commande publique il est
absolument indispensable de progresser
puisque l'État vous demande en effet de
plus en plus de contraintes il faut que
cela ait une traduction donc je crois
que nous serons vigilants
présidents nous aurons cette vigilance
là pour que le voilà il y a une réelle
amélioration sur la commande publique
j'ai aussi été très sensible madame
bourguignon au souhait que la traduction
de ces textes ne soit pas finalement
seulement de la RSE data
et en effet il faut éviter de trop
bureaucratiser de trop d'avoir des
contraintes administratives trop fortes
cela dit sur le fond moi je pense que
c'est absolument indispensable on a
aujourd'hui des crises qui nous touchent
crise sociale crise environnementale
crise géopolitique qui sont ailleurs
liés à tout cela qui nous demande d'être
extrêmement ambitieux donc cette
ambition qui est voulue dans les dans
les textes européens notamment la CSRD
on doit absolument y souscrire il faut
voir les moyens adaptés à chaque taille
d'entreprise mais là où j'ai un vrai
désaccord avec vous je ne pense pas
qu'on ne puisse compter que sur le
volontariat tout d'abord si on compte
que sur le volontariat et bien
finalement il y a une forme de
distorsion de concurrence qui ne
souhaitable pour personne donc voilà si
cela doit s'appliquer il faut que ça
puisse s'appliquer pour tout le monde il
faut bien entendu aussi que l'Union
européenne tire les conséquences de ses
choix c'est à dire que
la question des clauses miroirs que
quand il y a des importations au sein de
l'Union européenne on est on demande les
mêmes contraintes que qu'aux produits
qui sont fabriqués au sein de l'Union
européenne mais franchement je pense que
ce serait une occasion de manquer de ne
pas vouloir de vouloir échapper à cette
réelle ambition voilà monsieur vous
m'avez dit toutes les entreprises ont
conscience que c'est leur intérêt et le
fond certaines le font d'autres
n'ont peut-être pas le temps de s'y
mettre et
ne le font pas parce que elles n'en voit
pas l'intérêt donc je pense que ça
amènera des des entreprises vers ce
chemin il faut le faire avec des
obligations graduelles bien évidemment
mais pour répondre aux enjeux qui sont
devant nous je pense qu'on peut pas
simplement dire et bien
ce n'est pas volontaire et
parfois la somme des intérêts
individuels n'aboutit pas toujours à
l'intérêt collectif donc je pense qu'il
faut qu'on partage tous cette ambition
avec des des moyens adaptés il est
inutile en effet de multiplier le nombre
de salariés qui se consacreraient à au
remplissage de tableaux Excel bon ça
serait du temps perdu mais il doit
on a fait des auditions et on voit bien
que que cette que cette RSE entraîne une
modification du business model des
entreprises et peut être aussi un atout
de compétitivité ça peut amener à
davantage de
compétitivité donc moi je pense qu'il
faut qu'on voit collectivement comment
on peut s'emparer de ces textes comment
et on peut comment on peut en faire une
opportunité sur tout
en fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
nous qu'on a commencé à travailler sur
ces sujets avec nos groupes de travail
les entreprises étaient pour ces
dispositions pour être simplement avoir
un cadre et un cadre j'ai pas égalitaire
mais en tout cas un cadre qui permet
d'éviter ce genre de distorsion
simplement ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
aujourd'hui et là effectivement Medef on
a tout type de d'entreprise y compris
des très grosses donc c'est que même
pour les très grosses la marche est
énorme
c'est à dire que des gens qui étaient
favorables au démarrage deviennent
contre tellement il y a empilement et
complexification
ils en appellent pas forcément à une
simplification et à revenir en arrière
en termes de proposition c'est
simplement que la marche est énorme donc
il faut de la progressivité dans les
critères de la lisibilité dans les
différents systèmes c'est pratiquant
pratique c'est à dire que c'est pas un
jugement idéologique sur le fond d'une
vision différente d'un modèle de
capitalisme vertueux c'est simplement
que la marche est énorme et qu'à un
moment donné il y a des allocations de
ressources qui se font ou pas donc ça
c'est le premier point j'insiste à
nouveau sur un deuxième point c'est que
oui il faut y aller mais je crois que je
vais marteler dans cette audition
j'avais pas du tout prévu de le faire
mais ça me semble tellement évident à
l'audition que il faut véritablement
qu'il y ait une incitativité de la
politique publique pour aller plus loin
que le volontariat on est d'accord avec
vous c'est le volontariat ne suffira pas
si on veut faire la grande
transformation
transformation vite et de tous il faut
une incitativité de la politique
publique pour se faire et donc là ça va
être donc ça peut être inscrit au C2i
des appels offres on a déjà évoqué les
exemples et là je vais aller un peu plus
loin c'est vraiment une réflexion sur le
fond mais à l'envers d'une politique
publique c'est peut-on se poser la
question de la conditionnalité des
exigences réglementaires
vous voyez d'habitude nous les
entreprises on nous parle on nous pose
la question de la condition dealité des
aides aux entreprises mais moi je pose à
la puissance publique la question de la
conditionnalité des exigences
réglementaires s'il n'y a pas
réciprocité
une idée qui sera retenue
monsieur Burban
je crois qu'il faut qu'on se comprenne
bien
et alors je vais essayer d'être très
prudent dans les propos que je vais
tenir
et alors ça concerne ceci dit ça
concerne pas les travaux du Parlement
français mais ça concerne
justement le projet de directive
de directive européenne
si je prends le droit du travail
français le droit social français à des
moments le législateur c'est dit
finalement c'est mieux de renvoyer à la
négociation et aux partenaires sociaux
pourquoi parce qu'il y a des choses qui
sont dans les entreprises il y en a
d'autres qui sont pas dans les
entreprises je pense par exemple autant
de l'habillage et déshabillage
moi quand j'arrivais au bureau il y a
pas de temps d'habillage des habitages
par contre il y a certaines activités la
question se pose bref donc on renvoie
aux acteurs concernés aujourd'hui c'est
pas ce qui se passe ce qui se passe
c'est qu'on a une forme de technocratie
excusez moi de le dire comme ça qui fixe
des règles pour les entreprises et je ne
suis pas sûr excusez-moi de le dire
comme ça et ce que je dis c'est pas
anti institution européenne bien au
contraire mais je pense qu'il faut que
chaque acteur reste à sa place
dit différemment que l'on nous fixe des
objectifs
évidemment bon et on sait bien que ces
objectifs en fonction de l'évolution de
la société il y a des choses qu'on fait
aujourd'hui qu'on ne faisait pas il y a
20 ans et encore moins il y a 30 ans
donc ça on est d'accord simplement à un
moment donné il faut que tous les
acteurs soient à la bonne place donc ok
pour se fixer des bonnes objectifs
d'ailleurs je vais reprendre ce que
Sandrine Bourgogne a dit tout à l'heure
enfin à la fin de son son propos puisque
l'u2p partage totalement et c'est une
demande de l'UEP comme de la CPME à
savoir qu'il existe aujourd'hui des
référentiels par secteur voire par
branche professionnelle et nous
considérons que c'est ces référentiels
qu'il faut mettre en place après qu'on
dise à un moment pour l'instant on est
pour le volontaire il y a mais en
fonction des évolutions il faudrait que
toutes les entreprises respectent ces
règles-là pourquoi pas mais parce que on
aura pris des référentiels qui auront
établi par les professionnels qui
connaîtront l'activité
c'est ça qu'on demande on demande pas
d'être exonéré de tout et dire on va
faire n'importe quoi qui plus est on
sait bien que dans la RSE mais c'est
justement pour ça qu'il faut renvoyer au
professionnel c'est que et qui plus est
dans le contexte actuel où on a une
inflation
on a le problème des coups de l'énergie
on a le problème des matières premières
enfin bon bref en plus maintenant tout a
été fabriqué en Ukraine bon enfin non là
c'est une plaisanterie déplacer que je
retire immédiatement mais tout ça pour
dire que on a dans les démarches RSE ça
peut être du donnant-donnant qu'on a
enfin ou du gagnant-gagnant pourquoi
enfin moi je pense à mes coiffeurs on a
toute une démarche justement parce que
quand vous allez vous faire coiffer
malheureusement vous polluez l'eau enfin
en tout cas vous la salissez etc il y a
plein de mécaniques mais très pratique
au pratiques y compris pour
l'électricité parce qu'effectivement il
y a le choix ça enfin bref et des
techniques qui permettent donc à
l'entreprise c'est comme ça qu'il faut y
aller et comme ça les entreprises on va
leur dire mais vous voyez mais tu es
gagnant en plus tu fais des économies
qui plus est dans le contexte dans
lequel on est ben voilà mais c'est comme
ça qu'il faut y aller et pas laisser à
penser qu'on est là pour faire du
reporting pour le reporting et que ça
n'a pas de sens voilà et malheureusement
si on s'est exprimé comme ça aujourd'hui
c'est parce que par beaucoup de nos
ressortissants beaucoup de nos chefs
d'entreprises c'est ressenti comme ça
voilà donc
s'il vous plaît gagnant-gagnant
oui je voulais dire que nous partageons
cette ambition
en tant que chef d'entreprise en tant
qu'être humain j'espère que je laisserai
non pas mon entreprise mais le contexte
autour de mon entreprise relativement
sain pour mes enfants
si j'ai au moins réussi ça ce sera très
bien donc nous partageons tout à fait
cette ambition ce que nous voulons
seulement c'est que
ce
reporting ou cette information de
critères ce ne soit pas quelqu'un qui
nous l'impose alors qu'elle ne
connaissent pas la façon dont nous
interagissons
donc c'est ça quand on parle de
volontariat c'est pas volontariat par
entreprise c'est que on souhaite que les
critères sur lesquels vous allez avoir
les informations et toute cette data ce
soit des critères qui correspondent à
notre stratégie à notre façon d'être et
non pas
quelque chose qui tombe comme ça du ciel
de et en plus avec la très mauvaise
image que l'Union européenne peut avoir
quand on descend tout en bas auprès de
nos salariés il est absolument
nécessaire que cette ambition que vous
avez et que nous avons elles se reflète
par une
des rapports qui veulent dire quelque
chose
qui sont utiles et qui veulent dire
quelque chose c'est avant tout en slack
nous partageons tout à fait cette
ambition et je voudrais vous avez parlé
de est-ce que ça va attirer certains
salariés est-ce que ça va les garder
chez nous très certainement la jeune
génération est très friande de toutes
ces notions là et l'abord de très
volontiers lorsque l'on voilà on fait
des campagnes de recrutement même lycée
technique mais il faut pas oublier les
anciens
faut pas oublier non plus ceux qui sont
très loin dans les territoires qui sont
déconnectés des pouvoirs publics ceux
qui sont le fondement des gilets jaunes
nous on a été au premier rang le
mouvement des gilets jaunes il faut pas
les oublier cela cela faut pas les
laisser sur le bord de la du chemin et
nous le faisons en tant qu'entreprise
ils sont chez nous leur responsable paye
de mon entreprise du Loiret était la
femme qui était vent debout sur le
rond-point cacahuète de Montargis
pour le gilet jaune elle n'a reprochait
rien à l'entreprise elle reprochait tout
à l'état
merci de ce témoignage également est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres prises de parole pour
répondre aux rapporteur rien de
particulier on va on va conclure donc je
vous rappelle le cadre de notre mission
sur ce rapport on est parti du principe
remontant c'est à dire qu'on croit pas
trop ruissellement descendants
on a on a considéré que évidemment
l'Europe allait prendre des dispositions
et ça se confirme mais que les petites
entreprises les PME toutes celles qui
seraient en dessous des 250 salariés qui
est la barre retenue serait obligé
obligé de se conformer peu ou proue aux
exigences réglementaires avec les moyens
limités que vous avez évoqué c'est pour
cette raison là qu'on a commencé ce
travail
il y aura un rôle c'est peut-être
prétentieux de notre part un peu
pédagogique auprès de
l'entreprise on a retenu comme table
ronde pour la journée des entreprises de
13 octobre ce sujet là également pour
en rajouter non pas des paroles d'ex et
des paroles de chefs d'entreprise qui
vont dire pourquoi ils le font alors
qu'ils sont pas obligés ils sont pas
obligés par les textes mais ils sont
obligés par la chaîne de valeur à
laquelle ils appartiennent les objets
par le marché donc c'est une sorte de
volonté
c'est un peu contradictoire mais il faut
y passer et donc c'est cette idée qu'on
a voulu diffuser vous allez devoir y
passer même si vous êtes en dessous de
250 parce que votre demande
exigera que vous répondiez aux exigences
parce que les appels d'offres
indiqueront qu'il faut avoir
un répertoire sur ce sujet parce que vos
concurrents auront fait la démarche et
pas vous etc donc c'est ça notre notre
point de départ et donc je pense que les
éléments que vous avez développés les
uns les autres
vont tout à fait dans ce sens là c'est à
dire que cette parole d'entreprise en
fait et dont on a besoin pour enrichir
notre propos et essayer de peser un peu
comme je l'ai dit dans dans
mon propos tout à l'heure sur sur les
décisionnaires politiques et du coup
c'est loin du Parlement français bon
voilà voilà les quelques mots je vous
l'ai dit donc on n'est pas on n'est pas
du tout loin de vos réflexions on est
parti du de l'entreprise et des plus
petites en disant de toute façon ils
vont être obligés
volontairement ou non
il vaut mieux y aller alors évidemment
on passe un petit papier
remettre votre rapport à Bruxelles oui
oui on ira en délégation avec nos amis
non mais évidemment on passera oui c'est
pour ça qu'on va noter les Romains
changent indiquer de signature qui avec
les paroles assez fortes que vous avez
les uns et les autres développer je vous
remercie de votre participation c'est
toujours un plaisir de vous entendre en
tant que représentant des entreprises
sachez que notre délégation est très
sensible à vos propos et que évidemment
vous serez tenu au courant de nos de la
conclusion quand est-ce qu'on va
remettre le rapport
le 27 octobre
donc vous aurez un bon document pour
présenter à notre commission mesdames
les rapporteurs
femme que vous avez eu il y a un
complément masculin
très bien merci encore
et alors les collègues peuvent rester
pour la suivante table ronde suivante
qui va porter sur la conjoncture
économique
voilà
autre sujet
d'inquiétude merci beaucoup mesdames les
vice-présidentes messieurs monsieur le
président madame la secrétaire général
adjointe
monsieur secrétaire général
bien je vous propose de démarrer notre
nos échanges pour être très ponctuel
commencer l'être au Sénat
mes chers collègues merci de nous
rejoindre Martine Berthet
mesdames messieurs
on va poursuivre évidemment nos travaux
de l'après-midi
avec une seconde table ronde tout à
l'heure on a reçu des délégués de vos
différents syndicats sur la RSE et les
obligations d'une part pour les
entreprises jusqu'à 250 salariés qui se
généralise mais aussi les obligations
pour les pour les entreprises plus
petites qui vont se voir obliger de se
conformer aux exigences pour pouvoir
rester dans le coup des marchés des
chaînes de valeurs etc des appels
d'offres où il y aura la même exigence
auprès des plus petits entreprises donc
c'était la première table ronde
cette deuxième table ronde
à bord d'un sujet différent mais
évidemment qui n'est pas sans lien avec
le précédent en tout cas sur les
contraintes
supportées par nos entreprises on va
parler de la conjoncture économique dans
cette rentrée il y a beaucoup à dire une
façon parfois un peu
dramatique en tout cas inquiétante
je vous remercie donc
les différentes organisations
représentatives d'être présent pour
éclairer le Sénat je dirais en fin de
l'intervention on est en direct
et en vidéo sur le site internet du
Sénat en ce moment même et également en
direct sur Twitter et linkle
pour la CPME madame Stéphanie posa
vice-présidente délégué accompagné de
Madame Sandrine Bourgogne secrétaire
général adjoint qui était déjà dans la
première table ronde quel temps de
s'aérer un petit peu voilà et monsieur
Normand que le ministre la CPE pour le
Medef monsieur Christophe beau
je remercie directeur général accompagné
de Madame Christine Lepage directrice
générale adjointe en charge du pôle
économique
Madame Elisabeth vital Durand mais qui
est peut-être vous
vous supplez voilà merci d'être là
et Monsieur Antoine Portelli direction
des affaires publiques que nous je salue
à cette occasion pour le métier Monsieur
Frédéric Poirier coprésident du métier
et accompagner de Monsieur monter
délégué général et
Monsieur bonis qui était également
présent tout à l'heure
pour assurer le lien
pour l'UDP monsieur Burban également
deux fois couronné
secrétaire général de l'u2p accompagné
madame Thérèse note chargé des relations
avec le Parlement donc merci vraiment à
tous de consacrer un petit peu de temps
à cet échange enfin qui va plutôt être
de votre part
une explication de la situation il y a
malheureusement pas trop échangé mais il
y aura peut-être quand même quelques
questions
malheureusement je l'ai dit les sujets
d'inquiétude ne manquent pas en cette
rentrée et je vous remercie par avance
de la franchise avec laquelle vous
pourrez partager avec nous à la fois vos
préoccupations et vos préconisations
c'est pas juste un exercice de style ces
rencontres
on a vraiment besoin
de connaître la situation précise de vos
Mandans en fonction des différents types
d'entreprises que vous représentez pour
pouvoir éclairer
nos décisions et surtout nos
interventions législatives en cette
période mouvementée
quel que soit les différentes hypothèses
d'inflation ou de croissance du PIB ou
encore les projections en termes
d'emplois comme de commerce extérieur
les voyants sont passés à l'orange voire
rouge et les entreprises tout comme les
ménages sont elles seront directement
impactés
vous pourriez en particulier évoquer
l'impact de l'explosion des coûts de
l'énergie sur les secteurs et
entreprises que vous représentez c'est
pour certains entreprises c'est
quasiment mortelles vous nous le direz
comment la conjoncture se traduit-elle
sur leur modèle économique leur
rentabilité leurs investissements les
éventuels projets de relocalisation
d'activités en France ou en Europe et de
sécurisation de leur chaîne
d'approvisionnement
risque-t-elle de mettre en péril le
financement de la transition
environnementale
c'est là qu'il y a un lien avec notre
sujet précédent le plan sobriété
énergétique annoncé par le gouvernement
est-il atteignable et dans quelles
conditions faut-il s'attendre à une
forte hausse des défaillances
d'entreprises
comment limiter la casse
vous aimerions avoir vos analyses et
propositions sur tous ces sujets et bien
sûr tous ceux qui vous paraîtraient
opportun et important
d'évoquer aujourd'hui
je ne serai pas plus long et je vous
remercie de nouveau de votre
participation et je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est une diffusion en direct
donc
vous pouvez exprimer
les différents éléments de votre
discours de cette façon je vous donne
maintenant la parole on va commencer
monsieur beau si vous voulez par le
MEDEF
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
chers collègues je vais tâcher d'être
assez synthétique parce qu'en fait je
crois monsieur le Président que ce que
nous avons à dire est assez déjà compris
dans la trame de questions que vous
venez dénoncer et que je vois bien à
travers cette trame de questions que
vous avez parfaitement en tête les
préoccupations des entreprises et les
sujets auxquels elles sont confrontés
ces temps-ci pour résumer je dirais que
à court terme la situation n'est pas si
mauvaise pour la plupart des entreprises
sauf celle bien entendu qui sont
confrontés à des multiplications parfois
par 10 ou par 15 de leur facture
d'électricité ou de gaz mais qu'au
global les indicateurs en tout cas tels
qui sont photographiés aujourd'hui sont
plutôt positifs l'emploi est dans une
situation très très bonne à tel point
d'ailleurs que jusqu'à encore il y a peu
la principale préoccupation des chefs
d'entreprise portée sur les recrutements
l'inflation est très forte beaucoup plus
forte que ces quelques années et même à
son niveau le plus élevé depuis des
années 80 mais quand on se compare on se
rassure comme on dit puisque elle est
moins forte en France que dans les
principaux pays européens limitrophes
ceci grâce notamment aux boucliers
tarifaires et aux mesures budgétaires
qui ont été prises les conditions
bancaires rester relativement bonne en
moyenne pour les entreprises je pourrais
vous donner quelques chiffres si vous
souhaitez mais on voit toujours une
progression des encours de crédit aussi
bien pour l'investissement que un peu
moins pour les crédits de trésorerie
mais ça reste globalement bien orienté
les taux moyen ont légèrement augmenté
mais reste relativement faible par
rapport aux espérances de rendement des
investissements en face et puis les
défaillances d'entreprises si on en
arrive au bout du raisonnement de la
situation économique certes ont augmenté
par rapport à la période du covid où il
y avait eu comme une cloche mise sur sur
ces questions mais à 40000
constatations de défaillances
aujourd'hui on constate que c'est quand
même moindre que le dernier chiffre en
période entre guillemets connus avant
covid qui était de 50000 en 2019 donc si
on s'arrêtait là si la photographie
était statique on pourrait être
relativement satisfait moyennant je le
redis quand même la situation très
particulière des énergos intensifs bon
mais quand on regarde les projections et
qu'on se on regarde ce que ce que 2023
nous permet de prévoir là les choses
sont beaucoup plus dramatiques
inquiétantes parce qu'on voit se mettre
en place un enchaînement qu'on a connu
dans d'autres décennies lointaines et
qui est caractérisé par un phénomène de
cercle vicieux entre l'énergie
l'inflation l'érosion des marges la
perte de confiance le resserrement de la
politique monétaire
la hausse des taux donc ils s'ensuit le
manque d'investissement
l’alourdissement de la dette publique la
perte de confiance des ménages la baisse
de la consommation bref cette chaîne
néfaste des funestes qui nous amènent à
la stagnation
alors si je reprends un tout petit peu
les choses je dirais que vous l'avez
très bien dit dans votre propos
productif tout part de l'énergie c'est
devenu après le covid et après la
période de de reprise de la croissance
très forte dans les économies
européennes notamment la principale
source de nos déboires alors moi je
pense qu'il faut déjà commencer par
revoir quelles sont les causes de cette
crise de l'énergie parce que il y a les
causes immédiates et puis les causes
plus structurelles moi j'en citerai 4 la
première cause c'est la désadéquations
entre une reprise plus forte que prévu
et les moyens mis en face d'offre
d'énergie toute l'énergie confondue bon
et donc il y en a eu un une des
adéquations assez classique entre
l'offre la demande pour faire court
la deuxième cause elle est évidemment à
rechercher du côté de du conflit
ukrainien et de notre choix d'alliance
qui fait que le principal fournisseur de
gaz des pays européens dieu merci pas de
la France mais de nos principaux voisins
à utiliser cette arme de rétorsion
contre les sanctions qu'on lui faisait
par ailleurs
le troisième élément qui est peut-être
moins immédiat mais qu'il faut quand
même avoir en tête c'est l'absurdité du
polychimique énergétique européen et
singulièrement français depuis plusieurs
années où pour des raisons à la fois de
transition énergétique on a privilégié
l'énergie renouvelable laquelle comme
chacun sait est intermittente
et nous avons eu collectivement des
déboires tout le monde le sait sur le
renouvellement des centrales nucléaires
avec la nouvelle génération européenne
sans parler des fermetures inopinées de
centrales qui pouvait encore fonctionner
le tout dans un marché qui a énormément
besoin d'électricité parce que pour
faire de l'énergie verte ou par exemple
pour transformer demain de l'hydrogène
et bien il faut de l'électricité c'est
nous avions en France la chance d'avoir
une énergie électrique fortement
décarbonée dont on a probablement
abîmer les atouts à long terme
donc il y a vraiment un problème de
polysémique énergétique depuis longtemps
dans notre pays et puis le quatrième
élément il est encore plus ancien il
date d'il y a plus d'une vingtaine
d'années c'est le Market design conçu
par l'Union européenne dans le cas des
directives de libéralisation du marché
d'électricité et du gaz et on voit bien
aujourd'hui que ce qui était perçu comme
positif il y a encore quelques années
comme facteur de baisse des prix de
concurrence etc aujourd'hui s'avère
absurde avec un prêt électricité qui est
accroché au gaz avec une logique qu'on
peut comprendre si on est ingénieur qui
est la le fait que c'est la dernière
unité de production engagée au moment du
pic qui forme le prix or c'est souvent
une unité au gaz et comme le gaz s'est
envolé l'ensemble des prix électriques
s'est envolé mais tout ceci n'a pas de
sens en réalité du point de vue
macroéconique puisque la plupart de la
production écrite aujourd'hui n'est pas
au gaz et notamment en France
donc nous sommes prisonniers de cette de
ce market design qui ne sert pas les
intérêts français depuis le début
d'ailleurs depuis la directive de 97 et
dont nous sommes contents que la
président de la Commission européenne
est enfin reconnue l'humanité en disant
qu'elle allait mettre sur le métier la
refonte de ce market design mais pour
qu'il soit refondu il faudra des années
puisque ça passe par des directives donc
il y a un grand besoin de mesure
urgentes immédiates pour prévenir les
effets d'enchaînement que je citais tout
à l'heure sur le prix d'énergie donc
c'est là qu'on en vient à votre question
sur le plan de sobriété et sur les
efforts qui sont déployés pour essayer
de maîtriser les prix d'énergie je crois
qu'il faut que toutes les
toutes la palette d'instruments soient
mobilisées le plan de sobriété est vise
à baisser les volumes
et quand on quand on écoute le présent
de RTE ou d'autres autorités en la
matière on peut espérer que
effectivement nous n'aurons pas de short
Edge pour parler en mauvais français cet
hiver si les conditions climatiques sont
correctes si des efforts la nuit sont
faits et le 10% en deux ans proposé par
le gouvernement nous paraît assez
largement atteignable bon mais en
réalité le vrai problème aujourd'hui
n'est pas un problème de quantité c'est
un problème de prix et pour les
entreprises on en compte environ 300 qui
ont une forte proportion d'énergie dans
leur compte d'exploitation on a vu des
explosions x 10 avec des contrats
parfois qui étaient qui arrivaient à
leur terme et qui
réclamaient d'être
prolongé à des tarifs spots total tout à
fait inatteignables ça provoque
évidemment des clés sous la porte ou des
chômages partiels pour une certaine
durée qu'on ne sait pas quantifiée et
qui sont évidemment des situations
dramatiques avec des effets en chaîne
parce que souvent ce sont des industries
qui sont clés dans des chaînes de valeur
et si elles se mettent à l'arrêt elle
provoque ensuite d'autres inconvénients
bon voilà je veux pas être beaucoup plus
long mais c'est vrai que l'énergie et la
principale préoccupation et ensuite tous
les mots qui en découlent que j'ai cité
tout à l'heure dans le cercle vicieux
qu'on peut craindre si ce matérialise
trop rapidement voilà monsieur le
Président et puis je reviendrai ensuite
s'il y a des
après merci Monsieur le Directeur
général on va on va faire dans l'ordre
des croissants de des de la dimension
des entreprises représentées ces
symbolique allez merci monsieur le
Président alors je vais prendre les
choses un peu sur un autre prise
pas aussi positif quand même parce que
je pense que la situation est déjà plus
grave que celle décrite en tout cas pour
un certain nombre d'entreprises
concernées par effectivement l'énergie
je vais juste se faire un tout petit
retour en arrière sur les la depuis la
reprise économique pour vous donner un
peu l'enchaînement puisque nous
monitorons moi le moins l'activité des
entreprises de taille intermédiaires
pour voir un peu leur comportement en
termes d'activité d'investissement et
leur perspective
bon ce qu'on a vu évidemment c'est une
très forte reprise économique des
mesures qui ont été prises je pense à la
baisse des impôts de production
et du plan de relance et les effets ont
été assez remarquables on n'avait pas
encore partagé tous mais 2021 et l'année
les investissements étaient les plus
dynamiques jamais mesurées mais de très
très loin et la création d'emploi aussi
la plus forte jamais mesurée dans nos
entreprises pas uniquement les ETI mais
je pense que c'est absolument général ce
qui veut dire que la politique de
l'offre a un véritable retour sur
investissement je pense qu'il faut
l'avoir vraiment ancrée à un moment
donné on va rentrer dans une période
effectivement beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus compliqué
si nous regardons l'image de ces
monitorings depuis le printemps
on voit que la donne a changé évidemment
bien sûr le conflit a fait bouger les
lignes très fortement sur l'énergie mais
il a aussi fait bouger les lignes sur
les marchés je prends des quelques
statistiques qui ne sont pas des
statiques de production et de transport
les volumes de transport baisse - 7%
donc ça veut dire que même si les
chiffres d'affaires de nos entreprises
progressent parce que l'inflation est là
facialement les volumes transformés dans
notre pays baisse et ça je pense que
c'est un point qu'il faut prendre en
compte c'est qu'on produit d'ores et
déjà moins en France depuis plusieurs
mois et ça c'est ça ne se voit pas dans
les chiffres d'affaires parce que
l'inflation encore une fois des produits
de transformation est forte ça peut
aller jusqu'à 20% dans les produits 25%
dans les produits agricoles 15 à 20%
dans d'autres métiers mais ce que nous
produisons sur notre territoire en
volumétrie a déjà a commencé à déjà
commencer à baisser ça je pense que
c'est un point qu'il faut qu'il faut
regarder
l'aspect énergétique effectivement est
déjà impactant il le sera encore plus
l'année prochaine puisque évidemment les
contrats
qui ont été passés en
2022 font apparaître des doublesment des
triplements des quadruplements je peux
prendre mon exemple d'entreprise j'ai
mon électricité à 9 centimes l'année
prochaine elle sera à 30
c'est une évidemment je ne suis pas
électro intensif mais ceci étant mais
fournisseurs le sont donc ça aura des
impacts de toute façon dans ma chaîne de
la valeur pour ce qui est de ma
transformation ce sera maîtrisable mais
je sais que mes fournisseurs d'acier mes
fournisseurs de carton mes fournisseurs
éventuellement de verre vont se
retrouver dans des situations qui les
obligeront à demander des hausses de
prix voir à arrêter leur production donc
risque un moment donné de rompre les
chaînes d'approvisionnement et c'est là
aussi un des dangers au-delà au-delà des
marges et pour avoir monitoré tout
dernièrement 140 ETI nous savons d'ores
et déjà que certaines vont être vont
voir leurs résultats purement et
simplement effacés alors que l'année
dernière elles étaient florissantes voir
seront même en pertes
uniquement sur le poste énergie donc
déjà l'impact est considérable attention
aux coupures aussi j'insiste parce que
l'arrêt d'une unité de production
coûtera beaucoup plus cher
que le coût d'un bouclier ou que le coût
d'une protection là on peut avoir un
moment donné je sais que l'appréciation
va être donnée parfois au préfet de
pouvoir décider hors secteur stratégique
qui peut être arrêté ou pas il faut être
très attentif sur les impacts sociaux
puisque ce sera une mise sous cloche
d'outils de production le coût pouvant
derrière être absolument
considérable avec des effets possibles
de cascades puisque évidemment si vous
n'avez plus certains composants vous ne
pouvez plus assembler le reste du
produit l'automobile est un exemple
actuel avec les puces
voilà mais si un moment donné il nous
manque des composants pour finaliser un
produit bien c'est tout dépend
industriel qui pourrait s'arrêter donc
là il va falloir aussi avoir un un
regard tout à fait particulier sur
la manière dont on va s'organiser et
avec le plus en plus possible de de
concertation en amont comme pendant le
covid je pense qu'il faut avoir
exactement la même méthode puisqu'on va
se retrouver à un moment donné à devoir
peut-être confiner certaines activités
économiques j'espère le moins possible
mais nous ne sommes pas à l'abri si un
moment donné l'électricité au gaz venait
à manquer donc là-dessus il faudrait
être très attentif
pour ce qui est de la compétitivité
il y a un sujet qui va revenir pendant
la la le projet de loi de finance et la
CV bon c'est un sujet qui évidemment est
compliqué on comprend que les équations
économiques financières de l'État sont
complexes les discussions avec les
collectivités évidemment sont j'imagine
tendues mais c'est une nécessité
aujourd'hui nos entreprises sont
percutées par cette situation
énergétique par tous les intrants qui
vont
aussi être j'irai qui vont augmenter
dans la foulée parce qu'il faut pas se
leurrer si on continue à produire tous
les énergies intensives vont augmenter
leur prix le seront ou voilà donc nous
aurons un moment donné des réductions de
marche c'est réduction de marge existent
depuis quelques mois elles sont
confirmées de plusieurs points cette
deuxième baisse des marges risque un
moment donné encore de fragiliser nos
entreprises alors même que nous avons
toujours et on le répète deux fois plus
d'un pot de production en France qu'en
moyenne européenne ce sera donc beaucoup
plus difficile à absorber pour nos
entreprises que leurs voisines
européennes qui pourront qui n'auront
pas ce poids permanent et nous espérions
nous espérons toujours que cette CVE
sera en tout cas annulée en une seule
fois ce qui permettrait de réduire la
difficulté ou les difficultés auxquelles
vont être confrontées nos entreprises
un dernier point par rapport à la
décarbonation et la transformation elle
va s'accélérer monsieur le Président par
les prix
c'est quelque chose qui va mécaniquement
accélérer l'autoconsommation dans les
entreprises qui va mécaniquement faire
accélérer certains investissements qui
étaient décédés simplement ça arrive à
un moment difficile évidemment dans les
choix des entreprises alors capacité
peut-être serait-il intéressant sur ce
sujet spécifiquement de mettre en place
peut-être un régime de suramortissement
qui encouragerait peut-être un certain
nombre d'industriels allez encore un peu
plus vite dans leur transformation
moi je peux vous donner des exemples
j'ai commencé à mettre en place de
l'autoconsommation j'accélère le
mouvement je sais que beaucoup d'autres
et ici mettent peut-être un mécanisme de
ce type permettrait-il de faciliter la
tâche un certain nombre d'entreprises
au-delà de la simplification qu'il faut
aussi mettre en place puisque c'est pas
tout d'avoir envie de faire il faut
aussi que la législation et les
contrôles et les difficultés ne
ralentissent pas trop les projets mais
ça c'est je sais que c'est dans le cas
de la simplification qui est en cours le
texte sera bientôt présenté mais en tout
cas ça ça pourrait accélérer et
permettre à certaines entreprises
de pouvoir buter plus rapidement dans
leur dans leur modèle de mix énergétique
merci Monsieur Poirier
alors CME madame posa oui merci
donc je rejoins ce que ce que le métier
disait en la situation est beaucoup
moins positive en tout cas au deuxième
semestre que ce que j'ai entendu
précédemment donc je suis moi-même chef
d'entreprise dans le secteur de la
propreté et malheureusement dans nos
entreprises il n'y a pas que l'énergie
dans les entreprises en général du tissu
économique français ce qui joue un rôle
même si aujourd'hui c'est effectivement
très pondérant on est vraiment dans une
aire de changement très profond depuis
2020 depuis la crise je pense d'ailleurs
que ces changements étaient déjà un peu
initiés à l'avance mais la crise n'a
fait qu'accentuer tout ça
concernant l'activité puisqu'on parlait
d'activité ce qui est un peu inquiétant
enfin ce qui est inquiétant c'est le
ralentissement de l'activité qui
commence depuis le deuxième semestre
puisqu'on a une croissance qui est
proche de zéro et les prévisions 2023
malheureusement ne sont pas plus
optimiste et ceci ça a été confirmé
d'ailleurs par une enquête qu'on a menée
au niveau de la CPME en juin juillet sur
nos adhérents nous avons eu 2400
répondants et si la situation du premier
semestre leur semblait plutôt favorable
celle du deuxième leur paraissait
beaucoup plus compliqué
on avait d'ailleurs un recul de chiffre
d'affaires pour 31% d'entre eux déjà en
juin juillet donc ce qui n'est pas
négligeable et une baisse du taux de
marge pour 44% d'entre elles pour rappel
quand même la France a le taux de marge
le plus faible d'Europe donc ce qu'on
constate c'est que le moral est moins
bon le climat des affaires recule on a
une baisse des carnets de commandes
petit à petit l'inflation le manque de
personnel bref je suis désolé mais on
n'est pas dans une euphorie dans une
euphorie
on a sur cette enquête 93% de nos
répondants qui se disait avoir été
impacté par les hausses de prix et pour
un tiers forcément ça engendré enfin
forcément ça engendrait une hausse de
coût de revient mais pour un tiers ça
représentait plus de 10% de coûts
revient supplémentaires ce qui n'est pas
négligeable et souvent cette hausse et
c'est vrai aussi sur la main d'oeuvre
sur la masse salariale puisqu'il y a eu
beaucoup renégociation de salaire on y
reviendra
cette hausse souvent n'arrive pas à la
répercuter sur les clients quand vous
vendez à des particuliers vous pouvez
quand c'est du B2B c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué parfois sur le marché privé on
arrive à sortir notre épingle du jeu en
revanche sur les marchés publics c'est
souvent compliqué puisqu'il y a des
formules de révision qui ne nous
permettent pas de réviser les comment
dire les prix d'augmenter les prix au
fur et à mesure
qu'on a aussi dégagé de cette étude
c'est qu'on avait quand même 59% des
entreprises qui avaient déjà commencé à
limiter leur consommation d'énergie pour
justement pallier à cette hausse qui
commençait et en revanche il nous
remontait quand même un problème de mise
en oeuvre soit parce que il cherchait
des alternatives et les alternatives
malheureusement n'existaient pas soit
parce que le délai de mise en oeuvre
était parfois un peu long et donc ça ne
activité pas suffisante pour pour
permettre à l'entreprise de maintenir
ses marges en termes d'investissement
cette enquête disait aussi qu'on avait
50% des entreprises qui n'avaient pas
investi au premier semestre et qui ne
souhaitait pas le faire non plus au
second semestre donc on voit bien qu'il
y a quand même un ralentissement des
investissements ce que nous pensons
c'est que les changements qui ont lieu
actuellement sur l'environnement peuvent
inciter à investir sur des nouvelles
technologies sur des véhicules
électriques encore faut-il qu'on ait les
énergies les possibilités aussi de le
faire quand moi qui suis chef
d'entreprise j'ai regardé un peu à
changer ma flotte de véhicule
aujourd'hui sur le marché il y a pas
vraiment de de véhicules qui puisse
correspondre en termes d'autonomie et
puis quand vous voulez équiper votre
entreprise de bornes d'installation
électrique un ça coûte cher 2 pour
trouver quels sont les aides les
subventions auxquelles on a droit on a
du mal j'ai voulu organiser moi sur mon
bassin d'emploi une réunion
avec les chefs d'entreprise en localité
ça fait 10 jours qu'on essaye d'appeler
l'ADEME pour qu'ils interviennent et
l'ADEME ne répond pas ça sonne dans le
vide donc là encore je pense qu'il y a
des choses à faire est-ce qu'on peut pas
travailler sur un interlocuteur unique
en région qui puisse aider les
entreprises dans les différents
investissements ça serait peut-être une
piste on parlait d'emploi c'est vrai que
l'emploi a fortement augmenté dans le
secteur privé puisque on a plus 180 000
postes dans le secteur privé notre
enquête fait ressortir que 51% des
entreprises cherché à recruter en juin
juillet
et 94% avaient du mal en fait à trouver
les personnes soit pour absence de
candidat 74% quand même soit par un
manque de compétences 47%. donc on voit
que le marché du travail est tendu et
saturé mais ça je pense que dans cette
assemblée on en est bien conscient mais
ça freine aussi l'activité économique
24% d'entre elles sont confrontés aussi
un fort turnover alors les principales
raisons c'est se consacrer à autre chose
ou changer de secteur d'activité des
fois parce que on est débauché par la
concurrence en a des opportunités plus
intéressantes ailleurs et parfois aussi
parce que ça permet de rééquilibrer Vie
privée vie professionnelle
c'est simplement un constat mais ça veut
dire que demain il y a des métiers et
c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui qui
n'attire plus du tout je suis dans la
propreté et nous en faisons partie comme
la restauration comme la sécurité ça
fait partie des métiers fortement
touchés
dans cette étude ce qui ressort
également c'est que c'est lié à l'emploi
84% des dirigeants souhaitent une
réforme de l'assurance chômage donc
voilà on est en plein en plein dedans
puisqu'on a été auditionné récemment
mais on voit bien que c'est un vrai
sujet et puis concernant la hausse des
salaires on avait 65 % quand même des
entreprises qui avaient déjà augmenté au
premier semestre leurs salariés et 58%
qui disaient qu'ils allaient le faire ou
le refaire donc ce qui est quand même
pas négligeable on voit bien que les
entreprises jouent le jeu et augmentent
les salaires et celles qui pouvait pas
forcément augmenter les salaires de
manière collective elles ont mis en
place ils ont eu recours à d'autres
modes de rémunération l'épargne
salariale des primes individuels et des
primes collectives donc on voit bien
qu'il y a quand même dans les TPE PME
une vraie volonté et une vraie prise en
compte aussi des difficultés des
salariés
concernant les défaillances et les
radiations effectivement je rejoins
Christophe beau on est encore à un
niveau inférieur à 2019 même si on sent
que ça s'accélère et je discutais
d'ailleurs avec la médiation des
entreprises il y a une quinzaine de
jours qui nous disait qu'il n'avait
jamais eu autant de saisie au mois
d'août
que que cette année donc on voit bien
qu'il y a un sujet qui qui
arrive sur la fiscalité je rejoins
complètement il faut qu'on arrive à
conserver la compétitivité voir à
améliorer la compétitivité de nos
entreprises en poursuivant la diminution
des impôts de production ça c'est un
fait en vraiment ciblant la fiscalité
locale pour que toutes les entreprises
soient concernées et une des craintes
que les entreprises les TPE ont c'est
qu'effectivement pour compenser le
manque de budget des collectivités il y
a une hausse des impôts diverses qui qui
arrive
donc ce que nous préconisons c'est que
les TPE PME puissent faire partie des
discussions sur les pistes de
financement des collectivités pour
éviter justement
cet effet et puis
les entreprises craignent aussi une
hausse de la fiscalité foncière enfin ce
qui n'est de ce qui n'aide pas
[Musique]
enfin ce qui fait peur aussi la des
grosses craintes c'est toutes les
nouvelles réglementations qui tombent
les nouvelles réglementations vous avez
dû en parler dans le cadre de la RSE on
a le sentiment en fait d'avoir un comme
un gros nuage qui aurait au dessus de la
tête des entreprises des TPE qui vont
toucher dans un premier temps cette
réglementation plutôt les gros groupes
mais qui par capillarité ça va descendre
sur les TPE PME alors deux choses il y a
des tailles d'entreprises des
entreprises qui ont les capacités de
travailler sur ces sujets parce qu'ils
ont quand même quelques fonctions
supports et puis il y a les TPE et là je
pense que Pierre pourra certainement en
dire davantage mais qui n'ont pas les
forces suffisantes en interne pour
pouvoir travailler sur ces sujets et
puis faut pas oublier que tout ça ça
entraîne des lourdeurs administratives
des coups pour l'entreprise
et l'idée c'est aussi de faire attention
à assurer une équité entre les
entreprises européennes merci beaucoup
merci Madame la vice-présidente vers
monsieur Burban
merci monsieur
le Président c'est toujours compliqué
d'intervenir en dernier parce que je
vais être un peu redondant alors moi je
voudrais juste dire que ce que j'ai
entendu de Christophe beau de Frédéric
Poirier et de Stéphanie posa je ne vois
aucune contradiction parce que je vais
moi-même me contredire
voilà le premier point parce que il y a
les chiffres et ensuite il y a le
ressenti et puis il y a effectivement
tous les nuages qui s'amoncellent comme
la très bien dit Stéphanie
sur les chiffres et de toute façon on
les connaît tous puis on a les chiffres
macros on sait qu'elle est la croissance
française depuis la sortie du covid on
sait aussi quelle est la croissance de
l'emploi et je voudrais confirmer tout
ça puisque nous on fait chaque trimestre
une enquête auprès d'un panel
représentatif de
7675 entreprises je suis très précis
dans les secteurs de l'artisanat du
commerce et des professions libérales et
effectivement
jusqu'au 30 juin mais ça allait très
bien
jusqu'au 30 juin l'activité est repartie
on a même aujourd'hui la majorité des
activités
qui sont revenus avant la situation
covid donc
2019 bon donc ça ça c'est là pour le
coup on s'est incontestable parce que si
scientifique etc et comme ça a été dit
aussi avec des créations d'emplois qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui puisque malgré tout
qu'on devait pas le chômage il a baissé
voilà
et comme l'a dit Christophe et ça je
partage parce que moi je peux vous
assurer que pendant les vacances j'avais
la tête comme ça
d'atelier restaurateurs de
de boutiques qui me disait mais ils sont
partis où
les gens puisque on n'arrive pas à
travailler pour la première fois pendant
les vacances et ça ça contribue
largement à aussi faire tasser la
croissance française pour la première
fois dans les zones touristiques j'ai
constaté la fermeture d'activités de
café-restaurant
je n'avais jamais vu ça voilà et
pourquoi parce qu'il y avait pas voilà
et donc pour beaucoup de nos entreprises
en tout cas pour les entreprises que je
représente et quel que soit l'activité
parce qu'on dit oui mais dans le
bâtiment c'est compliqué c'est dur
machin oui mais les cafés restaurants
c'est si c'est là mais même chez les
professions libérales en pharmacie on a
des problèmes alors certes il y a eu la
période covid etc et bon
expert-comptable ça devient compliqué
pour recruter dans l'expertise comptable
bon c'est traditionnellement pas des
métiers qu'on considérait comme
compliqué donc ça ça reste quand même
parce que avec tous les nuages qui
s'annoncellent il y a quand même ce
problème là et juste en volume quand
même et nous on le fait puisque c'est
vrai que nous notre enquête elle porte
en valeur évidemment il y a l'effet
inflation inévitables mais même en
volume alors on le fait pas sur toutes
les professions mais pour nous en volume
bâtiment et travaux publics ils sont
encore en croissance et en plus ils ont
dépassé allègrement le niveau de 2019
voilà et pour l'instant c'était alors
attention une fois que j'ai dit tout ça
une fois que j'ai dit tout ça
souvenez-vous premier semestre comme l'a
dit Christophe en fait on a été surpris
de la reprise on a été tous très surpris
et du coup
ça suivait pas et les chaînes ne
suivaient pas
donc il y a ça
et donc même si ça se tasse un peu on a
toujours des problèmes
d'approvisionnement c'est vrai dans le
bâtiment mais c'est pas que vrai dans le
bâtiment parce qu'il y a des problèmes
aussi dans le secteur alimentaire pour
un certain nombre de produits de base
qui rentre dans les fabrications
on a également évidemment mais ça tout
le monde l'a dit et puis tout le monde
le sait parce que on nous en parle tous
les jours matin midi et soir c'est le
problème de l'énergie le problème
d'électricité le problème du gaz donc
tout ça est une évidence alors une fois
qu'on a dit tout ça et et et là on se
retourne vers la délégation
sénatoriale aux entreprises nous ce
qu'on compte enfin ce qu'on attend de
vous bon
on a bien conscience que le quoi qu'il
en coûte c'est fini et que de toute
façon
c'est nos impôts de demain de tout un
chacun et des entreprises demain bon
donc on sait bien qu'il faudra rester
raisonnable et qu'on ne peut pas raser
gratis toute sa vie pour autant il y a
des dispositifs parce que au moins en
tout cas nous c'est le sentiment qu'on a
enfin en tout cas l'image qu'on a de ce
qui a été fait on doit toujours saluer
l'action du gouvernement pendant la
période de covid qui a su accompagner
les entreprises et c'est bien parce que
s'il y avait pas eu cet accompagnement
d'abord tous les chiffres prouvent il y
a eu moins de défaillances d'entreprises
et du coup ces entreprises elles ont
rebondi rapidement ce qui a expliqué
aussi un syndrome de tension mais ce
qu'il faut c'est poursuivre alors non
pas un accompagnement mais restez avec
les dispositifs qui existent alors dans
les dispositifs qui existent je pense en
particulier à la médiation du crédit
parce qu'effectivement on risque d'avoir
des tensions sur le remboursement des
PGE etc donc ça il faut absolument que
ce dispositif continue à fonctionner le
médiateur des entreprises aussi c'est
capital dans les relations entre les
entreprises parce que vous avez des
entreprises qui sont fournisseurs et
vous avez d'autres qui ont besoin de ces
fournisseurs donc c'est important et
puis également
à Bercy a été mis en place un certain
nombre de communités de crise justement
pour suivre les évolutions je pense au
comité de crise bâtiment mais il y a
aussi un comité de crise énergies et
donc ça il faut que ces dispositifs
perdure et continuer à fonctionner et
l'autre élément parce qu'il y a eu il y
a des dispositifs alors il y a certes le
bouclier notamment pour l'électricité et
le gaz mais vous avez notamment pour les
entreprises qui font plus de 3% qui ont
dans leur chiffre d'affaires ou plutôt
exactement l'électricité et le gaz
représente plus de 3% de leur chef
d'affaires pour ces entreprises il y a
un dispositif qui permet de les
accompagner on s'est rendu compte que
beaucoup d'entreprises la grande
majorité des entreprises françaises ne
savent pas que ça existe donc il y a un
problème aussi d'information des
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place et
d'informations pour faire en sorte
en actionne les bons leviers pour éviter
effectivement que ces entreprises soient
obligées soit d'arrêter ce qui serait
catastrophique
soit se retrouve dans des situations
compliquées
merci beaucoup alors madame posa
peut-être un complément je peux rebondir
juste sur effectivement ce que disait
pierre et ça me fait penser à ce que
disait Christophe également
en fait je crois que les banques ont
leur rôle à jouer de manière assez
fondamentale et pour le coup elle sait
pas aussi positif en tout cas pour les
tpeme on sent que les les robinets si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi comment ça se
resserrer un peu et c'est un peu plus
compliqué
pierre parler du PGE
c'est vrai que la CPME demande depuis
très longtemps une un allongement des
PGE qui aujourd'hui est possible via une
certaine procédure en revanche ça met
l'entreprise en défaut de paiement et
nous ce que l'on souhaiterait c'est
pouvoir supprimer cette mise en défaut
de paiement qui est une cotation Banque
de France qui soit moins bonne ça
s'entend il y a un endettement
supplémentaire en revanche la mise en
défaut de paiement de l'entreprise c'est
un pied tombe pour le dirigeant et c'est
aussi des encours qu'on supprime c'est
les assurances crédit qui tombent donc
je pense que là la au niveau de des
banques et des solutions possibles ça
fait partie des choses qui pourraient
être envisagées
merci de ces précisions on est
on est vraiment attentif à toutes ces
précisions que vous nous donnez parce
que vous n'ignorez pas on est très
attaché à nos territoires c'est c'est le
boulot des sénateurs on a donc les
relations avec le directeur de la Banque
de France départementale avec les
banques de la place et donc c'est
précieux ce que vous nous dites pour
pour que le la formation circule quoi
par notre canal finalement donc je me
tourne vers mes collègues est-ce qu'il y
a des questions
une question
sébastien Laurent merci monsieur le
Président bonjour à tous
Alors moi quand je suis beau disait que
tout part de l'énergie évidemment je
pense que l'économie c'est de l'énergie
transformée donc j'ai envie d'applaudir
[Musique]
comme tu disais on est en relation avec
nos territoires donc moi je suis du Val
d'Oise prochainement je vais voir le
président du tribunal de commerce le
président du comité d'expansion
économique du Val-d'Oise etc pour savoir
comment sur le territoire se traduit
cette période un peu folle que nous
vivons depuis quelques années depuis
quelques mois quelques années maintenant
la question que j'avais c'est par
rapport aux banques effectivement
comment comment elle se comporte les
banques vis-à-vis de vous et par rapport
au secteur d'activité aussi parce que il
y a quand même des secteurs d'activités
qui me semblent-ils ne connaissent pas
la crise on a fait un rapport sur la
cybersécurité et à part les
problématiques de d'emploi et de trouver
des compétences et de recruter certaines
activités ou dans tout ce qui évidemment
pharmaceut tout ce qui est industrie
pharmaceutique qui viennent de vivre
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il soit
tellement pénalisée mais par contre sur
le secteur d'activité notamment tous
ceux qui ont besoin d'énergie
effectivement
c'est elle va être extrêmement difficile
et nous on aura arbitré
entre par les acvae là nous les
collectivités
dans le Val-d'Oise une agglomération de
300 000 habitants a eu son estimation la
semaine dernière de d'augmentation des
prix du gaz niveau du gaz tout ce que
vous avez dit c'est exact c'est un monde
de fou quelque part fois 6 fois 6 le gaz
X6 le président de la Commune c'est pas
comme une affaire il a réunion avec le
préfecture à l'état est bien en peine de
nous répondre mais grosso modo essayent
d'expliquer aux collectivités qu'il va
falloir faire qui va se débrouiller
parce que elles sont sorties pas trop
mal avec le covid et c'est vrai que la
fermeture des cantines tout ce qui est
autour de la des enfants des économies
aux collectivités mais là fois 6 gaz pas
électricité c'est pas qu'on va faire
donc on est complètement conscient ici
que la CVE il faudra la supprimer
notamment mais par rapport à nous en
plus sénateur vis-à-vis des
collectivités comme comment faire une
part de TVA
et on a l'impression de pas s'y
retrouver parce que ce que vous dites
on le sait puis des années avec cette
politique sur l'énergie est folle en
plus c'est un des nausées
irrité de Gaulle les Pompidou des messes
mères enfin c'est complètement dingue
mais là par rapport à l'Allemagne
notamment noir a tous été pris d'énergie
très très bas
je pense que donc les secteurs
d'activités qui sont les plus
consommateurs vont être beaucoup plus
touchés et par rapport à d'autres
activités
qui s'en sortent alors je sais pas
peut-être comment comment aider plus à
passer ce cap difficile j'espère qu'on
aura un retour un prix d'énergie correct
voilà merci Sébastien donc deux
questions l'une sur sur les banques
l'autre sur la diversité par filière
voilà situation
si tu veux Christian peut-être une
question et puis on prendra l'ensemble
d'accord très rapidement je suis un élu
sénateur du Haut-Rhin donc où se situe
fsenheim et c'est extrêmement criant de
vérité cette erreur d'avoir fermé
cette centrale nucléaire pour des
raisons on reviendra pas dessus d'un
accord politique qui aujourd'hui nous
coûte cher coûte doublement cher puisque
c'est une usine qui ne produit plus
c'était quand même c'est un centre de
production une centrale nucléaire
elle était
sécurisée elle était post focushima
l'employé 2000 personnes en plus de ça
nous fait un trou évidemment de au
niveau de l'emploi au niveau des
ressources financières pour les
collectivités locales donc bon c'est on
en parle souvent mais c'était une erreur
absolument agréable enfin
terrible c'est presque un scandale
d'État mais bon c'est comme ça et petite
anecdote sur le effectivement sur le
l'augmentation du prix du gaz je te
rejoins je suis élu à Houssen auprès de
la communauté des Halles merci de Colmar
et le transport de bus se fait au gaz
budget
2022 pour faire rouler ses bus
300 5000 euros prévisionnel 2023 2400
donc vous voyez que il y a effectivement
les entreprises qui seront impactées par
ce cette augmentation du coût de
l'énergie mais les collectivités
territoriales le sont dans les mêmes
proportions et dans la même mesure hélas
ma question est plutôt sur le marché de
l'emploi du du travail
évidemment dans dans nos
circonscriptions on rencontre les chefs
d'entreprise et c'est quelque chose que
l'on entend depuis
depuis le mois de juin ou même déjà un
petit peu avant ce cette difficulté à
recruter et à trouver de et à trouver de
la main d'oeuvre alors il y a des
endroits géographiquement où il y a des
tensions effectivement lorsqu'on est
frontalier il peut y avoir des tensions
avec l'attirance de de l'emploi qui se
fait en Suisse ou en Allemagne en ce qui
nous concerne
par contre on a l'impression quand même
qu'il faudrait réformer ce marché du
travail quand j'étais maire de ma petite
commune il y a encore pas très longtemps
on trouvait des étudiants pour le mois
de juillet mais pour le mois d'août on
arrivait plus à trouver personne donc on
a quand même l'impression que les gens
préfèrent les loisirs et préfèrent
en apparence je raccourcis je schématise
mais c'est un petit peu ça aussi on
pourrait voir des étudiants aussi
travailler dans les bars dans les
restaurants au mois d'août mais
effectivement moi je juillet on arrive à
recruter au mois d'août on trouve on
trouve plus personne
en dehors de cet exemple qui n'est pas
un bon exemple
ne faudrait-il pas revoir le marché du
travail pas que l'indemnisation chômage
je sais pas revoir les contrats voir
plus de souplesse on voit que les gens
ont envie de travailler pour eux de
trouver une forme de contrat avec des
gens effectivement qui travaillent
peut-être plus en indépendance que de
salarié de son entreprise est-ce qu'il y
a des des voix ou des réflexions qui
sont qui sont ouvertes
à ce niveau là
Martine Berthier peut-être ce sujet
précis
alors justement une partie de mes
questions portaient sur ce
cette recherche de salariés
effectivement qui sont soulignés dans
tous les secteurs moi je suis sénatrice
de la Savoie dans le tourisme ça a été
catastrophique effectivement vous disiez
certains restaurants sont obligés de
fermer le soir parce qu'il ne trouve
personne c'est certain c'est un manque
un manque d'activité effectivement mais
il y a tout un tas de professionnels je
suis pharmacien effectivement dans les
pharmacies on ne trouve plus ni de
préparateur ni de pharmacien adjoint
donc ma question portait sur alors d'une
part effectivement ce que mon collègue a
soulevé avec ce souhait
d'auto-entreprise de travail plus facile
à organiser par rapport à sa vie
professionnelle
d'auto-entreprise et de plateformes donc
de mise en relation est-ce que vous vous
voyez cet effet justement sur le manque
de recrutement les entreprises arrivent
à faire est-ce qu'il y a
un enjeu à ce niveau là je pense que
enfin personnellement j'en suis
persuadée mais voilà comment comment est
l'impact pour vous comment le
ressentez-vous et puis également
j'aimerais revenir sur le travail d'été
des étudiants et pas que le travail
d'été d'ailleurs les petits emplois
qu'ils occupaient alors quand je pense
qu'on est nombreux de ma génération et
de celle d'après aussi quand on faisait
nos études dans travailler toutes nos
vacances voilà pour avoir un peu
d'argent est-ce que ces étudiants là ils
sont toujours sur le marché pour les
petits emplois pour les emplois d'été
est-ce qu'on les voit toujours moi je
n'ai pas ce sentiment donc voilà je ne
ressens pas ça de la part de des
étudiants actuels
[Musique]
moins voilà quels sont aussi là les
impacts merci
merci chers collègues de vos questions
donc je les résume que vous puissiez
répondre mesdames messieurs
question sur la banque financement
finalement les entreprises puisque vous
avez évoqué le sujet avec une sensation
déjà de voilà un petit peu
le robinet se ferme un peu la situation
différenciée des branches
en termes de de situation face à aux
difficultés que vous avez évoqué s'il y
en a qui sont pas touché du tout
plus ou moins ou beaucoup
quelques exemples et puis le problème
général de l'emploi du rapport au
travail finalement c'est un peu ça qui
est évoqué quand on parle de faire
évoluer les différences de contrats
nouveaux etc président de la CPME c'est
illustrer là-dessus en disant CDD les
gens refusent le CDI mais ils ont qui
bénéficient quand même de l'aide voilà
il y a quand même une situation
compliquée là-dessus donc sur ces trois
sujets qui veut démarrer
allez monsieur beau je voudrais qu'on
peut peut-être faire un pardon
vous voulez c'est parti d'accord merci
beaucoup merci président d'abord je
voudrais revenir deux petits points
anecdotiques mais
quand vous avez donné la parole tout à
l'heure en parlant de détails
successives d'entreprise le Medef ne
représente pas les grandes entreprises
uniquement à chaque fois nous avons
toutes tailles d'entreprise parmi nous
adhérents ensuite deuxième petite
précision j'ai été étonné effectivement
de l'impression d'un tel optimisme parce
que je suis pas sûr qu'on est bien
entendu au départ heureusement pierre
rectifié non j'ai parlé quand même de
situation dramatique donc et je suis
tout à fait d'accord pour reformuler
quelques pierres Lafaye à la
photographie du premier semestre qui est
les statistiques sont sont bonnes il
faut le reconnaître et les perspectives
du second semestre et de l'avenir sont
tout à fait dramatique je l'ai dit et je
crois qu'on n'est pas là pour faire une
compétition de
[Musique]
le débiteur potentiel et c'est pas
forcément parce que les banques ont une
attitude plus restrictive c'est parce
que les taux d'intérêt et vinces en
quelque sorte quelques projets soit
immobilier soit des projets autres du
marché donc il faut pas voilà
deuxièmement sur les PGE spécifiquement
nous on n'est pas
pessimiste au point de demander des
adaptations incessantes sur ce produit
qui a sa logique interne et qui doit
s'inscrire dans un encadrement
communautaire des aides qui se fait que
on peut pas non plus obtenir la lune et
il est vrai que il y a cette question du
défaut qui est liée à une
restructuration du PGE mais il faut pas
non plus confondre les choses c'est le
défaut au sens default anglo-saxon c'est
à dire par rapport à la réglementation
bancaire qui oblige des banques dès lors
qu'elle restructure un crédit à le
mettre dans leur colonne des crédits non
performants avec des conséquences sur
les fonds propres que la banque met en
face ça n'a rien avec le défaut de
paiement tel que nous on l'entend en
droit français qui peut déboucher sur un
dépôt de bilan donc je pense qu'il faut
pas du tout se faire peur à l'excès en
stigmatisant cette notion de difold au
sens anglo-saxon qui fait partie de la
réglementation bancaire prudentielle des
normes de balles etc et avec le défaut
de paiement qui est Dieu merci ne n'a
pas à être provoqué par un remboursement
de danité de PGE
voilà ce qu'on peut dire de mon du point
de vue du Medef sur la situation
bancaire sur les secteurs d'activité
différenciées alors oui je crois qu'on
peut dire qu'il y a une très grosse
différence entre des secteurs qui se
portent encore relativement bien et
d'autres je l'ai dit tout à l'heure qui
sont très impactés par la dépense
énergétique on a tous en tête des cas
très très frappants notamment dans
l'aluminium avec l'aluminium Dunkerque
ou avec l'usine de ce genre de Maurienne
ou d'autres Duralex qui a fait la une de
des médias en annonçant sa fermeture
temporaire donc tout ce qui est
processus de production qui engage de
l'énergie est très impactée mais aussi
le textile habillement qui sont aussi
des filières dans lesquelles beaucoup
d'énergie est consommée on l'oublie
parfois donc tout ceci ce sont des
secteurs qui souffrent terriblement on
pourra peut-être monsieur sénateurs vous
envoyer un tableau avec une situation je
dirais sectorielle mais effectivement
les situations sont très très
différentes d'un secteur à l'autre
sur les conséquences de tout ça sur le
budget des collectivités locales nous
nous avons toujours considéré qu'il
fallait que les quantités locales soient
compensées d'une éventuelle baisse de la
CVE bon et on ne méconnait pas les
difficultés budgétaires qu'elles peuvent
rencontrer vous en avez cité un exemple
sur les hausses d'énergie après moi je
rejoins le président Poirier le signal
qui serait envoyé par un PLF dans lequel
la CVE serait abaissé en deux en deux
morceaux si on comprend bien le scénario
qu'est-ce qui se le gouvernement c'est
un signal qui est très mauvais parce que
il touche à la confiance dans la parole
donnée ça fait des mois et des mois que
le rendement dit qu'il va baisser la CVE
en une seule fois et accorder cette ce
supplément de petite de l'offre pour
reprendre l'expression du président
Poirier aux entreprises et arriver au
pied du mur on retire le tapis c'est le
défaut traditionnel de la fiscalité
française que l'on connaît depuis des
années où on change de pied à chaque
fois et on insécurise les contribuables
qui sont les entreprises en premier lieu
les particuliers aussi mais en donnant
des des indications contradictoires par
rapport à ce qui avait été prévu et
c'est ça au fond le problème de principe
profond que ça pose indépendamment du
problème financier de decevoir retirer 4
milliards sous les pieds sur l'emploi
alors là on aborde des sujets plus
compliqués
je pense que le fait que
de telles difficultés de recrutement et
que le marché de l'emploi au fond
dysfonctionne dans l'autre sens par
rapport à ce qu'on a connu pendant 20
ans
il y a plusieurs causes il y a celles
que le gouvernement va essayer de
traiter
en plusieurs temps déjà un premier temps
avec la réforme de l'assurance chômage
de l'année dernière qui a mis tant de
temps à se mettre en oeuvre parce
qu'elle a été comme on le sait tous
plusieurs fois attaqué dans le concept
d’état bon là il y a un processus qui
s'ouvre nous allons y participer dans le
cas d'une concertation ouverte par
ministre de du travail il y a une loi
qui est portée à votre examen et qui
commence à navette qui prévoit cela très
bien nous on pense qu'effectivement il y
a encore
des marges de manoeuvre à mettre en
place pour inciter davantage au retour à
l'emploi et éviter les situations de
permittence qu'on a pu observer ici ou
là soit dans l'emploi saisonnier soit
soit sous notre forme après il faut être
honnête et reconnaître que il y a
d'autres freins à l'emploi qui tiennent
par exemple à l'adéquation des
compétences donc ça touche la question
des formations alors là on peut se
rassurer pour l'avenir parce que avec
les primes qui ont été octroyées et la
dynamisation du du nombre d'apprentis on
est passé de 400 000 à 800 000 et
l'objectif affiché parlonnement c'est un
million donc oui on est tout à fait pour
cet objectif il faut pas là aussi
retirer le tapis sous les pieds en
termes de prime de la citation parce que
si on veut que les entreprises
recrutent des apprentis il faut bien
donner ses incitations qui ont été très
efficaces et c'est de l'argent bien
investi par le contribuable puisque ces
apprentis vont être ensuite directement
employables et ils vont trouver un
emploi
il faut aussi citer la mobilité qui est
un problème soit mobilité
domicile travail qui est souvent
problématique et puis l'attractivité des
emplois la balle est dans le camp des
entreprises on sait qu'il y a un certain
nombre de secteurs notamment le
restauration c'est bien connu mais
d'autres dans lesquels l'attractivité
est difficile et donc on a tous un
travail collectif à faire pour que
motiver pour motiver les gens
enfin pour terminer sur les stratégies
d'effacement alors je pense que c'est
plus plus complexe ça madame la
signatrice parce que l'effacement c'est
une des modalités très particulières que
certaines industries acceptent dans des
contrats où elle paie moins cher mais en
donnant la possibilité rte de leur
demander de d'abaisser voir de supprimer
totalement leur tirage
alors ça ne concerne qu'un tout petit
nombre d'entreprises ce qui nous
intéresse nous c'est les économies qui
peuvent être faits tous secteurs
confondus dans le tertiaire où je pense
qu'on a des marges de manœuvre sur le
chauffage sur l'éclairage sur la
climatisation etc c'est le sens des
propositions MDF a fait dès le 2 août au
ministre concerné dans le cadre du plan
de sobriété et c'est aussi le l'exercice
que nous faisons avec les partenaires
sociaux avec la CPME l'u2p et les
réseaux syndicales pour produire notre
d'ici quelques jours un relevé de
décision qu'on espère consensuel avec
des propositions concrètes pour
atteindre le type de plantes sobriété
bon mais je le redis et je terminerai
par là la question des volumes c'est une
chose mais la question des prix elle
reste entière et à ce stade n'est pas
résolu merci merci Monsieur Poirier
alors sur les banques le la situation à
côté ETI et en légère agression sur la
le niveau de réponse positive mais il
reste très élevé c'est-à-dire qu'on est
sur un on est monté très très haut poste
covid avec un niveau même de
satisfaction et assez étonnant on est
descendu de quelques points ça reste
tout à fait convenable il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui constaté du côté de thé mais
quand même une inflexion remarquée
depuis trois mois donc je pense qu'il y
a quand même effectivement un changement
est-ce qu'on peut vous dire si c'est
sectoriel ou pas sectoriel je pense que
c'était encore un peu tôt
ce qui est certain c'est que l'industrie
aujourd'hui est dans un niveau de stress
qui est incomparablement supérieur aux
autres secteurs d'activité ça c'est très
clair avec les niveaux de de d'énergie
que nous connaissons comme je disais
tout à l'heure vous avez un nombre
important d'entreprise je pense qu'on
est plus de 300 je pense qu'on est
plutôt à plusieurs centaines voire
au-delà qui vont voir leur situation
se dégrader de façon considérable voire
à passer en perte voir arrêter de
produire tout simplement nous avons
aujourd'hui une ETI sur 10 qui déclare
qu'elle va s'arrêter le produire
très probablement alors est-ce que c'est
gravée dans le noir je ne sais pas vous
dire mais en tout cas il y a 7 pays sur
10 qui ne peuvent pas répercuter
l'intégralité de leur coût donc les
marges sont très très impactées donc et
ça c'est évidemment extrêmement
concentré sur les gros secteurs de
consommation donc l'industrie de
transformation
l'agroalimentaire notamment sont dans
une situation très complexe
alors qu'elle doit affronter d'autres
sujets je vais pas rentrer dans le
détail de l'élevage ou autre où là on a
des situations extrêmement compliquées
donc
je pense qu'il faut faire quand même un
focus un peu particulier sur l'industrie
quand on parle d'énergie
le service même s'il est impacté
aujourd'hui nous le voyons les beaucoup
moins même dans l'informatique même les
gens donc c'est vraiment un point très
particulier avec un risque qui est quand
même très important vu le niveau de la
crise c'est que si nous ne mettons pas
rapidement en place un mécanisme de
plafonnement parce que là aujourd'hui
les particuliers sont couverts les
petites entreprises des bénéficient d'un
tarif spécifique mais les entreprises
PME d'une certaine taille et uti n'ont
rien et là nous avons des situations
vraiment très très complexes qui peuvent
arriver si nous ne trouvons pas une
solution dans les semaines qui viennent
j'ose espérer que les prochaines
réunions
européennes vont aboutir parce que c'est
vraiment
un mur de perte que nous avons devant
nous c'est
[Musique]
si on reste dans le schéma actuel ça va
s'arrêter c'est à peu près écrit avec un
risque de désindustrialisation nouvelle
comme on a connu en 2008 donc il faut
absolument sur ce point-là trouver des
solutions très rapides parce que c'est
c'est effectivement
les impacts sont
gigantesques potentiellement j'ai quand
est-ce qu'effectivement sur les sujets
de recrutement effectivement les
tensions subsistent
pas seulement sur les métiers qualifiés
mais aussi sur les métiers courants
effectivement
tout ce qui concerne l'apprentissage et
absolument positif les ETI comme toutes
les entreprises se sont beaucoup
mobilisées elles continuent à le faire
on appelle de nos vœux d'ailleurs que ce
mouvement se poursuive la formation
initiale notamment le l'enseignement
professionnel dont la réforme est va se
faire est très importante parce qu'on
peut pas seulement changer les gens
d'orientation il faut aussi parler
notamment les métiers qualifiés beaucoup
plus mettre l'accent sur la formation
et on a certainement beaucoup pas faire
et beaucoup pas améliorer les choses les
entreprises forment de plus en plus
elles créent des écoles nous on avait
des centaines de cas d'écoles internes
qui se sont créés donc la réforme de la
formation professionnelle à produits des
effets donc les entreprises se sont
emparées et investissent donc de ce
point de vue là on sait aujourd'hui
faire beaucoup plus facilement changer
les gens de secteur d'activité et de
sujets de la mobilité est effectivement
clair notamment avec un pétrole cher ça
c'est clair que les rayons d'action des
salariés se sont réduits bon les choses
peuvent changer je pense qu'avec le coût
de l'énergie qui pétrole qui est
actuellement revenu à des niveaux plus
acceptables peut-être que ce sera un
petit peu moins
sensible sur les sur le sujet de la de
la sobriété et de l'effacement
effectivement l'effacement c'est
vraiment un sujet très spécifique la
sobriété je pense que les entreprises
s'en emparent ce que je vous disais tout
à l'heure le signal prix va faire bouger
les entreprises assez rapidement le
c'est le pas de temps qui est
aujourd'hui très compliqué il faut deux
ans trois ans pour un projet de
transformation majeure de son outil de
production nous n'avons pas ce temps-là
devant nous avec la situation
énergétique actuelle c'est pour ça qu'il
faut absolument trouver des solutions le
plus vite possible
merci en continu peut-être les réponses
des différences intervenants
je mets un bémol je suis désolé mais
j'ai 14 ans de parcours bancaire avant
alors ça a changé parce que le secteur
bancaire mais
dès qu'il y a restructuration des
crédits et c'est le cas dans le PGE il y
a souvent mise en défaut de paiement de
l'entreprise
[Musique]
après on ressent aujourd'hui
une petite tension notamment plus grosse
difficulté
à obtenir des crédits court terme à
obtenir
des prêts pour investir avec des
garanties supplémentaires qui peuvent
être demandées en revanche j'ai pas de
chiffres
mais voilà on sent en tous les cas que
que ça se tend
sur la diversité par filière oui
effectivement on a des entreprises vous
parliez de la cybersécurité ils sont en
plein boom entre guillemets après ce
enfin là où il faut avoir quand même une
certaine vigilance c'est que c'est
aujourd'hui elles vont bien si demain
c'est un raz-de-marée sur d'autres
secteurs d'activités forcément il y aura
des conséquences sur les entreprises qui
marchent bien aujourd'hui et donc c'est
toute cette chaîne aussi qu'il faut
avoir en tête et conserver et je
comprends aussi la difficulté nous
comprenons les difficultés auxquelles
sont confrontées aussi les collectivités
parce que on a les mêmes difficultés
entreprises collectivités en fait quand
on quand on regarde bien
concernant le marché de l'emploi
oui ce que je voulais dire aussi au
niveau des filières on a en fait
aujourd'hui on a deux types
d'entreprises qui sont impactées il y a
celles qui sont impactées fortement par
l'énergie qui ont des fois des marges un
peu plus élevées mais qui de coups du
coup se trouve complètement anéanti voir
vont générer des pertes avec l'inflation
de l'énergie et on a beaucoup de
secteurs dans le service dans lesquels
on a fortement d'oeuvre bas salaire avec
des augmentations de salaire
conséquentes et là aussi on s'aperçoit
que les augmentations de salaire par
exemple dans la propreté il y a eu 7%
d'augmentation de salaire sur l'année et
on s'aperçoit que ça va mettre à mal
beaucoup d'entreprises du secteur parce
que quand vous avez un résultat net qui
est de 1 à 2% de votre chiffre
d'affaires et que vous avez 7 % de
salaire plus les primes individuels plus
les coûts d'hiver dont on vient de
parler forcément ça impacte de manière
de manière non négligeable
concernant le marché de l'emploi
alors là effectivement plein de choses
plus de souplesse revoir le code du
travail le marché du travail on
s'aperçoit effectivement qu'aujourd'hui
le CDU le CDI n'est plus le Graal pour
les salariés et encore moins d'ailleurs
pour les jeunes on leur propose des CDD
à la fin ils veulent pas de CDI ils ont
envie au delà d'une rémunération plus
forte qui peut motiver le CDD parce
qu'il y a la prime de précarité ils ont
aussi envie de pouvoir s'arrêter quand
ils ont envie de travailler enfin
s'arrêter de travailler quand ils ont
envie et reprendre quand ils ont envie
alors c'est pas forcément simple pour
nous dirigeants en revanche
il faut peut-être qu'on se pose la
question effectivement de comment on
devient plus agile comment le code du
travail
s'adapte à ces assez profond changement
de mentalité face au travail
le mois d'août oui on trouve personne
j'ai encore ce mois d'août là moi
personnellement on a refusé 15000 euros
de chiffre d'affaires parce qu'on
trouvait pas de personnel on appelait
les boîtes d'intérim on nous disait bah
non il y a plus d'intérimaires
les étudiants c'est revenu à plusieurs
reprises alors les étudiants ont un
rapport au travail aussi très différent
il commence et puis au bout de deux
jours ils ont pas envie alors ils
arrêtent ou où ils vous envoient un
message en vous disant bah j'ai un
problème de voiture je viens pas mais
c'est bizarre c'est le weekend du 15
août voilà c'est c'est des comportements
qu'on voit dans l'entreprise
réforme de la formation professionnelle
elle a porté ses fruits peut-être sur
certains domaines pour nous les TPE PME
elle a été moins favorable parce qu'il y
a plus de mutualisation et donc ça crée
des des possibilités de formation que
l'on a perdu qu'on avait grâce aux
mutualisations aux mutualisations
au niveau de la formation
ce qui est essentiel c'est de faire
coller davantage les formations à aux
besoins du terrain aux besoins des
entreprises et ça c'est un vrai sujet
aujourd'hui on remplit des classes
entières de chargées de com de alors
qu'en fait ben il y a plein
d'entreprises qui n'en ont pas ou
d'ailleurs les pauvres étudiants qui
sont en alternance ne trouvent pas
d'entreprises pour les accueillir donc à
un moment ils remettent la formation les
besoins en territoire pour faire coller
pour faire vraiment coller les besoins
avec le l'entreprise
c'est quelque chose qui voilà qui nous
semble important aussi bien d'ailleurs
pour la formation initiale et aussi pour
la formation continue parce que on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a plein de formations
continues qui sont plus forcément
adaptés qui ont des process je pense pas
nous dans notre métier on avait
certificat de qualification
professionnelle c'est minimum ou 170
heures de formation pour un agent
d'entretien quelqu'un qui a déjà une
expérience qu'on voudrait le faire
passer d'un niveau on appelle ça agent
machiniste classique à un aerp il faut
qu'il refasse 150 heures il y a pas
besoin de 150 heures donc vous voyez
c'est toutes ces choses là aussi qui
faudrait peut-être travailler et puis
favoriser les passerelles aussi entre
les différents métiers puisqu'on sait
qu'il y a des métiers qu'on verra moins
demain d'autres qui sont en émergence
avec ce qu'on est en train de vivre
notamment sur le plan environnemental
favoriser les VAE nous paraissent
intéressants quelqu'un a parlé de la
problématique de mobilité c'est vrai et
derrière mobilité j'ajoute logement on a
une vraie problématique de logement en
France peut-être qu'il y a quelque chose
à travailler avec Action Logement
puisque les statistiques ont l'air de
dire que les les fonds qui sont donnés
par les entreprises pour les logements
vont plus aujourd'hui enfin en tout cas
vont moins aux salariés des entreprises
ou aux jeunes qui décrochent un emploi
qui a d'autres population donc peut-être
qu'il y aurait aussi
quelque chose à faire
à ce niveau là
concernant la sobriété
on est en train nous de ces PME de
travailler simplement sur des bonnes
pratiques pour aider les TPE PME à avoir
un peu par quel boule prendre aussi bien
sur le plan vie quotidienne alors ça
c'est tout bête mais comment je fais
pour mieux qu'on maîtriser ma
consommation de d'électricité ma
consommation de gaz
moi par exemple dans l'entreprise j'ai
pris rendez-vous avec la personne qui
gère la chaudière pour voir si on peut
pas réduire c'est tout bête mais réduire
la nuit et puis c'est vrai aussi sur les
anciennes et les enseignes électriques
où on voit des entreprises des parkings
qui sont éclairés toute la nuit je pense
qu'il y a des choses à faire et puis on
travaille aussi sur des bonnes pratiques
au niveau numérique parce qu'on sait que
le numérique mange aussi beaucoup de
sur la sobriété sur les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre voilà je pense que j'ai
répondu à peu près à tout merci beaucoup
merci
Monsieur Burban
je vais juste me concentrer sur les
questions d'emploi
juste je vais en prendre pour une porte
ouverte mais parfois quand on parle sur
les difficultés de recrutement on a
l'impression que les secteurs qui sont
en difficulté de recrutement ne créent
pas des emplois c'est évidemment
totalement faux ils ont créé
en net c'est à dire que
et simplement malheureusement il y a pas
suffisamment de candidatures pour venir
travailler mais s'il n'y a pas de
candidature c'est qu'il y a un problème
de qualification en fait voilà puisque
et nous toutes les enquêtes qu'on fait
confirment il faut savoir quand même que
dans ceux qui ont des difficultés de
recrutement en tout cas dans les
entreprises qu'on représente dans un cas
sur deux il y a personne qui se présente
pour pour voir le poste
c'est quand même assez hallucinant c'est
à dire en fait on a l'impression comme
on est dans la même situation qu'en
Allemagne où il y a moins de 5% de
chômeurs
on en a encore un peu plus de 7 me
semble-t-il presque 7 et demi voilà donc
ça c'est ça qui est inquiétant
de mai malgré tout ces secteurs en
difficulté de recrutement créer
des emplois
nets bon ça c'est ma première
observation ma deuxième observation sur
la tractivité des métiers
toutes les branches professionnelles et
en particulier celles qu'on avait le
plus de difficultés mais travail à ces
problèmes d'attractivité y compris dans
l'hôtellerie restauration il
réfléchissent justement
à faire en sorte que les personnes
puissent avoir au moins weekend sur deux
parce qu'on voit bien que c'est les
aspirations etc bon donc de toute façon
déjà beaucoup de choses sont faites
il faut évidemment ça a été 10
poursuivre le développement
l'apprentissage parce que je pense que
ça restera ça reste l'outil le meilleur
pour justement
faire en sorte que les qualifications
qui répondent aux besoins des
entreprises
après
ça a été évoqué on voit bien alors
comment dire on se dit on a des
informations on a beaucoup de cas où
effectivement les jeunes ne vaudrait
plus décéder ils parce que alors pour
moi c'était une grande découverte parce
que à ce que je sache le CDI n'est pas
vraiment un fil à la pâte et que je ne
connais pas beaucoup d'employeurs qui
ont poursuivi leur salarié parce que ils
n'avaient pas respecté le préavis en
terme de de rupture de CDI en tout cas
au moins chez les non cadres voilà bon
ben voilà on me dit maintenant c'est un
fil à la pâte alors certes comme l'a dit
Stéphanie il y a une indemnité de
précarité etc avec le CDD mais bon nous
on pense qu'il faudrait que alors je
sais pas si ça relève de France
stratégie ou de quel organisme de l'État
mais qui est une vraie un vrai rapport
de fait alors peut-être le Sénat et je
sais pas s'il y a des outils
mais pour comprendre quelles sont ses
évolutions et vérifier
que c'est quelque chose de en général
parce qu'on a vu aux États-Unis qu'on a
parlé du Grand du grand départ je sais
même plus comment on l'appelle la grande
démission cette grande démission elle se
confirme pas en France bon donc il y a
d'autres phénomènes et nous on pense
qu'il faudrait les étudier ensuite
a été évoqué par madame la sénatrice le
l'idée des plateformes et l'aspiration
alors et le régime de la
micro-entreprise ou ce qu'on appelle
aussi historiquement le temps
entrepreneur alors
comment dire je fais partie d'une
organisation qui pense même si l'idée du
régime de la l'auto-entrepreneur et de
la micro était peut-être une bonne idée
parce que ça laissait à penser que tout
le monde allait pouvoir créer sa boîte
malheureusement on voit bien que ça a pu
créer un certain nombre de dérives voir
de contenu voire de distorsion de
concurrence je pense notamment au
secteur du bâtiment voilà alors et les
plateformes je pense alors excusez-moi
de le dire comme ça mais je pense que
c'est un peu le miroir aux alouettes
aujourd'hui effectivement je pense que
beaucoup de jeunes et ça c'est très bien
parce que nous en tant que représentant
des entreprises c'est ce qu'on attend
nous et en particulier dans le monde de
la petite et très petite entreprise il
faut que des jeunes viennent pour
reprendre ses entreprises donc c'est
super
donc cet aspiration a de devenir son
propre patron c'est bien après je dirais
et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion d'en
conseiller attention parce que quand
vous devenez votre propre patron c'est
plus de responsabilité parce que quand
vous rentrez quand vous êtes salarié
dans votre entreprise le matin vous
arrivez vous pourrez pas la question de
vos fournisseurs ou peut y avoir des
problèmes du fil des impôts de
l'URSSAF j'en passais des meilleurs et
puis si j'ai des salariés il faudra
aussi que j'ai un chiffre d'affaires qui
permette de payer les salaires etc donc
c'est aussi plus de responsabilités et
même et même celui qui travaille seul
c'est aussi des responsabilités parce
que malgré tout il faut des clients et
s'ils trouvent pas de clients ben ça
pourra pas marcher et alors mais bon
quand vous en avez parlé mais chez nous
le travail a fait ce qui se passe sur
les plateformes ça nous fait pousser des
boutons aujourd'hui forcer les constater
je pense notamment aux plateformes de
mobilité ou de livraison qu'en réalité
dans le comportement c'est plus une
relation comme si c'était une relation
avec un salarié et simplement qu'on
laisse la personne comme un travailleur
indépendant voilà donc
quand on parle qu'on va travailler sur
la réforme des retraites parce que on
crée les gilets jaunes de demain parce
que mais en ce moment on les a créé
puisque vous avez beaucoup de personnes
qui vont arriver à l'âge de la retraite
et qui n'auront pas leur nombre de
trimestres et n'auront pas leur annuité
etc et on va créer les mises heureux de
demain voilà donc il faut qu'on soit
très attentif
mais je reste quand même positif tous
ceux qu'on peut accompagner vraiment
vers la création d'entreprise il faut le
faire au contraire la France doit être
un vrai pays d'entrepreneurs
quel que soit la taille de ses
entreprises et évidemment quand on est
jeune ou
quand on a la trentaine et c'est plus
facile de créer une petite boîte qu'une
grosse boîte
merci est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
questions parmi les collègues
me rend et puis Florence allez Sébastien
juste sur une question sur les chaînes
de valeur et sur les goulets
d'étranglement qui avait été existant et
explosé au niveau du covid est-ce que
c'est revenu à peu près la normale où
vous prévoyez ça pour l'année 2024 ou
pas avant
c'était ma question et peut-être
au-delà de la question comment est-ce
que ces ruptures de
d'approvisionnement
peuvent vous conduire à changer votre
votre process et internaliser davantage
de process et deuxièmement sujet qu'on a
peu abordé la question de cours du
dollar et des effets sur
à la fois vos intrants importés qui sont
plus onéreux et
dans le sens inverse à l'exportation les
avantages voilà la balance avantage crue
pour vous du cours actuel de l'euro qui
est très bas
mais
on conclura sur ces réponses aux
questions qui veut commencer
allez monsieur on regarde les sur les
chaînes d'approvisionnement ça s'est
beaucoup amélioré on a aujourd'hui peu
d'entreprises qui se plaignent encore de
cette difficulté de manière critique
alors elle s'en plaignent encore de
manière gênante mais ça n'atteint pas
des seuils critiques il y a un chiffre
que je peux vous donner qui vient de la
Banque de France le nombre de chefs
d'entreprises qui estiment être
confrontée des difficultés
d'approvisionnement et passer de 60% à
50% et dans le bâtiment et passer de 50%
à 40% bon donc ça reste encore un
chiffrer élevé 40% mais encore une fois
c'est la criticité qui est la à beaucoup
baissé sur la question madame la
sénatrice c'est très compliqué parce que
je suis enfin pour qu'il y a un effet
sur le commerce extérieur à la fois des
prix et de la baisse de l'euro il faut
un petit peu de temps quand même parce
que il faut que les comportements des
acheteurs à l'étranger se modifient
honnêtement je n'ai pas de chiffres qui
montrent pour l'instant
un pick pour parler encore une fois en
bon français des exportations qui
seraient liés à la baisse de l'euro par
rapport au dollar et quand à la question
des prix un train en revanche elle est
beaucoup plus rapide à ce matérialiser
parce que comme l'a dit la Présidente il
y a pas toujours de possibilités de
répercuter dans les tarifs dans les
chaînes de valeur d'un fournisseur vers
un donneur d'ordre l'intégralité des
hausses de prix subit en amont donc le
problème est très présent à court terme
en amont et encore pas du tout
malheureusement
source de profit en aval
nous avons des éléments qui vont à peu
près dans le même sens
il y a quand même quelques secteurs
critiques tout ce qui est machine outils
aujourd'hui les délais sont doubles par
rapport à avant le covid c'est à dire
que quand vous faites un investissement
la machine que vous aviez avant en 6-9
mois mais entre 15 et 18 mois donc il
faudrait pas qu'elle arrive après la
bataille quand même c'est à dire que ça
peut aussi le remettre en question
certains investissements dès lors que la
réalisation est beaucoup plus longue et
il y a quand même des secteurs comme
l'automobile qui tournent toujours au
ralenti papa à cause de la demande c'est
parce que il manque les puces il manque
les équipements etc enfin tout ce qui
est véhicule
électronique et même l'aéronautique à ce
moment est ralentie dans sa reprise par
le le la disponibilité de certains
composants mais très très concentré sur
de l'électronique la situation à
énergétique peut recréer ce type de
tension
vous voyez des verriers qui s'arrêtent
vous voyez des aluminiers qui s'arrêtent
un moment donné des aciers j'ai des
informations de certains fournisseurs
qui me disent qu'ils vont ralentir des
hauts fourneaux donc si c'est pas sur
les prix ça va être sur les quantités il
y aura un moment donné certainement des
nouvelles tensions qui vont se créer sur
le dollar l'avantage entre le prix de
l'énergie
qui explose et la compétitivité de l'art
en fait elle est très négative pour nous
c'est les États-Unis en ce moment qui
vont très bien je le commerce extérieur
américain vis-à-vis de l'Europe va
s'améliorer parce que il y a de plus en
plus de composants de base qui sont fait
là-bas rien porté chez nous je pense que
c'est effectivement favorable à un
certain du commerce un peu de commerce
mais d'un point de vue général moi je
pense que c'est c'est plus négatif
aujourd'hui à cause de nos sujets
énergétiques que positifs donc
voilà enfin en tout cas moi je le vois
sur mes achats notamment acier qui sont
en dollars
la parité n'est pas favorable
je voulais juste effectivement confirmer
que
la problématique d'approvisionnement
elle est quand même très présente dans
le secteur de l'automobile on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui vous commandez un
véhicule vous savez pas notamment sur de
l'utilitaire sous quel délai vous allez
être livré c'est un an quasiment et
encore il s'engage pas sur sur des
durées
moi j'ai commandé un jumper au mois de
septembre le concessionnaire me rappelle
même pas parce qu'il sait plus quoi me
dire donc c'est quand même un sujet et
d'ailleurs les concessionnaires sont
inquiets parce que ça
ils ont du mal à conserver leur
commerciaux qui qui sont eux-mêmes payés
au moment de la livraison des véhicules
mais comme il livre plus alors ils ont
mis en place des rémunérations un peu de
substitution des modes de rémunération
différents mais ça ne suffit pas donc
voilà
voilà merci d'évoquer ces incidences
particulières spécifiques aussi
merci vraiment à chacun d'entre vous
d'avoir participé à cet échange précieux
pour pour nous puisque je voulais dire
on va pour ma part je réunis vendredi
dans mon département les
le même aéroport de de
syndicats et des chambres consulaires
pour faire un point sur la conjoncture
départementale donc on est vraiment sur
ces sujets là en prise directe et c'est
important de vous entendre aujourd'hui
on s'était en direct on va aussi faire
passer l'information à nos collègues
puisque
pour l'instant tous les sénateurs ne
sont pas encore dans nos murs puisque on
ne redémarre la session ordinaire que le
4 octobre
voilà mais la délégation d'entreprise ne
cesse jamais de travailler merci encore
de votre présence